mick de cette pandémie est ce que tous
les pays africains vont être impactés
continent va voit vraiment une de ses
pires années 70 dernière même si les
conséquences selon différentes selon les
pays
nous avons là une situation où pour
sauver les économies africaines il va
falloir créer de la liquidité il faut de
l'argent pour pouvoir se tirer
d'affaires pendant cette année 73
millions de personnes touchées quand
même par une crise alimentaire dans
quelle mesure cette pandémie du colis de
19 risque d'aggraver les choses
associer la troisième crise parce que là
par la solitaire qui est là et la crise
économique nous allons avoir une crise
de sécurité alimentaire
[Musique]
devenez
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
elle l'essentiel de l'information avec
nos invités toujours tenus à bonne
distance et de reporters sur le terrain
l'actualité toujours dominé en grande
partie par la crise du coronavirus en
france et dans le monde voici les titres
l'hôpital en première ligne dans la
crise du coronavirus le secteur attend
beaucoup des négociations qui débutent
le 25 mai avec le gouvernement pour à un
ségur de la santé une promesse faite par
emmanuel macron plus fort de l'épidémie
à 35 heures augmentation des salaires
après les annonces l'hôpital attend des
actes concrets après le retour en classe
d'écoliers 185 mille élèves de collège
de zone verte ont fait la rentrée en se
pliant un strict protocole sanitaire
aujourd'hui dans le port obligatoire du
masque après un premier week end est
confiné la prudence est plus que jamais
de mise avec l'apparition de 25 nouveaux
foyers infectieux depuis la fin du
confinement en europe a en italie
notamment le bilan quotidien passe sous
la barre des 100 morts le pays rouvrent
progressivement commerces cafés et
terrasses la basilique saint pierre de
rome également tout un symbole
la russie elle devient le deuxième pays
le plus touché au monde derrière les
états unis et dénombre plus de 290000
contamination nous serons en direct sur
place à moscou
[Musique]
le personnel hospitalier attendons des
réponses concrètes de la part du
gouvernement
elle malgré les annonces du premier
ministre de la demie ce pardon de la
santé ce week-end et la volonté du
gouvernement d'instaurer un ségur de la
santé les syndicats des milieux
hospitaliers maintiennent la menace
d'une mobilisation le 16 juin à créteil
aujourd'hui les dizaines de soignants
ont manifesté leur mécontentement
écouter on a vécu des moments hyper
difficile pendant la période covic là ça
va un peu mieux mais on a on a manqué de
matériel
nous a envoyé des renforts des gens qui
étaient fausses
donc ça a été très très difficile
pendant un moment et là aujourd'hui
montre qu'on est mécontent de ce qui
s'est passé et que si on avait eu plus
de lits
dorée a sans doute eu le passé comme en
allemagne
voilà c'est l'heure des comptes et c'est
l'heure de relancer nos revendications
il y aura peut-être des prochainement d
des mobilisations nous nos
revendications n'ont pas changé c'est
une augmentation salariale que nous
promet une belle macro et on attend de
voir c'est d'abord concerner tout le
monde
c'est à dire tous les professionnels pas
que les soignants à l'hôpital également
des administratifs et les services
techniques sont très souvent oublié on
veut également des embauches on
travaille en sous effectif depuis trop
d'années et on veut des budgets
hospitaliers à la hauteur des besoins de
la population puisque on supprime depuis
des années des lieux de vie et qu'on
n'arrive plus à répondre aux besoins de
la population
on a des personnels qui sont épuisés
physiquement épuisés psychologie font
des heures sup initialement devait être
payé presque gracieusement et grassement
finalement il ya du retard on sait même
pas si on va les avoir les primes que
tout le monde devait toucher par les
sept fiasco enfin voilà on va sur des
promesses que personne ne tient enfin ce
gouvernement ne tient pas et dans
l'impression qu'ils donnent à chaque
jour qui évolue on appelait ce qui m a
faussement sur une jambe de bois
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
fabrice di vizio avocat spécialisé dans
la défense des professionnels de santé
bonsoir fabrice di vizio merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
olivier verrons a présenté les axes de
son plan chez nos confrères du jdd ce
week-end parmi les mesures des
augmentations de salaires pour les
personnels un plan d'investissement une
remise en question des 35 heures ça
c'est peut-être pour la partie à
discuter pourquoi ce maintien des
mobilisations dans le secteur
hospitalier
ça n'a pas rassuré ben si vous voulez le
problème c'est qu'on a bien vu dans
cette crise que la parole du
gouvernement étudie parole donc il faut
quand même cruellement se méfier c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui
alors laquelle je vous parle alors que
la crise n'est pas finie certains
membres du personnel hospitalier dont
toujours pas de masques ffp2 c'est à
dire que vous prenez le bloc opératoire
qui va reprendre les infirmiers de bloc
donc pas de masques ffp2 tous qu'il ya
un décalage comme d'habitude entre le
discours du gouvernement et les actions
du gouvernement ce qu'on cherche c'est à
rassurer les soignants mais elle est
rassurée avec des paroles avaient reçu
avec des discours et on peut
légitimement comprendre que ces derniers
on est assez ont fait des discours et
demande maintenant à ce qu'on passe à
l'action
et ça je pense que c'est vraiment le mot
d'ordre alors des discours justement aux
à quelles sont les priorités aujourd'hui
les points du gouvernement justement qui
semble encore litigieux après les
propositions d'olivier veron ou semences
est une question selon-vous de confiance
non c'est pas seulement une question de
confiance c'est à dire qu'il ya deux
aspects si vous voulez y ait un court
terme où il faut dans les mois qui
viennent éviter les contaminations à la
chaîne à l'hôpital et donc reconstitué
ce stock de ffp2 il est distribué
massivement ça c'est le premier point ça
c'est pour le court terme et pour le
moyen et long terme il faut quand même
maintenant très clairement repenser
l'hôpital il va falloir à un moment si
vous voulez arrêter les suppressions de
lits complètement stupide qui ont été
menées il va falloir refondre
complètement la politique de santé
hospitalière et finalement donné aux
soignants ce qu'ils méritent
c'est à dire une reconnaissance et à
qu'on arrête avec les médailles n'est
pas les soignants de l'epad mais dan
hill valley juste qu'on leur donne les
moyens de travailler j'ajoute qu'il faut
bien comprendre que des soignants dans
la rue lorsqu'il se bat il se bat pas
pour eux faire ça n'a pas de sens ils se
battent effectivement pour pouvoir on
l'a vu dans le cadre du colis d' éviter
de choisir des patients qu on réanime
éviter d'être une chaîne de
contamination il se bat pour les
patients en fait et c'est bien ça le
drame de ce pays c'est qu'on n'a pas
compris que les soignants ne sont pas
dans une attitude de revendications mais
dans une attitude finalement de
revendications pour la population vous
parliez des masques les fameux masques
ffp2 qui sont de votre viseur
aujourd'hui on le disait vous défendez
de nombreux personnels soignants est ce
qu'il ya des actions qui seront intentés
justement après cette pénurie qui a
causé beaucoup de tort au secteur ah
mais je pense qu'une action immédiate à
l'hôpital nous avons mis en demeure
l'intégralité ou presque des hôpitaux
universitaires de france de fournir des
ffp2 et aux infirmiers de bloc
opératoire si après demain cette mise en
demeure reste sans effet nous déposerons
des plaintes contre tous les hôpitaux
universitaires de france par par
principe et surtout les infirmiers de
bloc opératoire ne reprendront pas les
blocs et ne se présenteront pas les
exerceront leur droit de retrait il
n'est plus question alors qu'on est plus
dans la pandémie en tant que tels que
les soignants continue de payer de leur
vie les carences de ce gouvernement nous
avons le nous avions le temps de
reconstituer ces masques si le
gouvernement ne l'a pas fait bien il
leur qu'elle l'assumé
aujourd'hui c'est facile de trouver des
fp2 il suffit de les faire venir mais
des infirmiers de bloc opératoire ne
reprendrons pas le chemin du bloc
opératoire précisément s'ils n'ont pas
de masques ffp2 vous dit fabrice di
vizio c'est ce gouvernement il était
encore le temps d'agir est ce que nous
serment il était encore temps d'agir et
si oui sur quel argument vous vous
fondez mais il était forcément temps
d'agir parce que concrètement si vous
voulez on nous a expliqué au début mars
qu'on ne pouvait pas commandé de masques
par vous vous comprenez parce que la
crise était telle qu elle est
internationale et qui a personne qui
pouvait en avoir facilement alors on
sait que c'est faux mais peu importe
aujourd'hui la crise est derrière nous
et des ffp2 pour que la majeure partie
de la crise derrière nous et on s'est
effectivement que des ffp2 vous pouvez
en avoir en huit jours il ya aucun
problème tout le monde en avait fait 2
bsa en à l'industrie automobile
effectivement on a qui a pas de problème
donc il suffit maintenant pour ce
gouvernement de mettre des moyens de
protéger les soignants et ça c'est
facile
aujourd'hui si vous voulez on n'est plus
dans ce débat d'une espèce de tensions
internationales d'approvisionnement ça
n'existe plus a donc toute la question
si on n'a pas ces masques aujourd'hui
pour les infirmiers de but
j'assume c'est juste parce qu'on veut
pas le leur donner et parce qu'en fait
on est dans une indifférence absolument
caractérisé à l'égard du personnel
soignant converse de belles paroles mais
finalement en attendant mieux
alors une autre plainte un celle du
collectif des médecins ses 19 celles
postées contre edouard philippe et agnès
buzyn accusé de ne pas avoir pris les
mesures nécessaires face à l'épidémie de
kovy de 19 est ce qu'on peut vraiment
intenté un procès à l'état pour sa
gestion de la crise et notamment contre
le premier ministre et l'ancien ministre
de la santé incite d'ailleurs l'actuel
ministre de la santé également qui est
visée 1
alors moi je ne fais pas de procès à
l'état pour sa gestion
je fais un procès à deux ministres
commencent trois et non pas pour des
fautes de gestion mais parce qu'ils ont
potentiellement commis des infractions
pénales ce qui est très différent
madame busin à elle même déclaré dans
les colonnes du journal le monde 17 mars
qu'elle savait qu'elle était la première
à savoir qu'elle a averti tout le monde
et qu'elle avait manqué les parties en
pleurant du ministère parce qu'elle
savait le tsunami qui allait s'abattre
sur nous le tsunami qui s'est abattu sur
nous nous l'avons vu est effectivement
aucune mesure n'a été prise
et bien ça c'est exactement ce que le
droit pénal sanctionne
il n'est pas question de critiquer une
gestion qui est quelque chose qui de
notion beaucoup très beaucoup trop vague
il est question de reprocher à madame
busin monsieur philippe alors qu'il
savait dit madame busin de ne pas avoir
pris les mesures qu imposer les
circonstances c'est ça qui est puni par
le droit pénal et c'est ça si vous
voulez qui a été mis en évidence dans
les plans l'appelant les plainte que
nous avons déposée et nous reproduisons
l'histoire nous revivons l'histoire
aujourd'hui avec les images que vous
avez là où finalement on nous promet de
l'un deux choses comme on nous a promis
que des masques avait été commandée que
tout était en ordre au début de la crise
mais on voit ce que ça a donné
et c'est exactement ce qui va continuer
à se passer aujourd'hui dans ce pays
parce qu'on a une déconsidération
profonde pour les soignants aujourd'hui
on est
donc à l'heure du décompte finement
l'état justement a pris bien soin de
décharger les élus d'une éventuelle
responsabilité pénale notamment les élus
locaux est ce que ça va vous sembler
être une bonne chose vous êtes en tant
qu'avocat à ses châteaux
je vais vous dire tout ça c'est de la
politique parce que endroit ça ne change
absolument rien la responsabilité des
élus
elle était déjà extrêmement difficile
depuis la loi fauchon de 2000 à mettre
en oeuvre et on a fait toute une
communication autour d'une prétendue aux
douanes misty parce que tout le monde
s'est emballé parce qu'on a plus
confiance dans ce gouvernement mais la
vérité ici c'est que cette loi ne change
rien à la responsabilité des élus qu'ils
soient effectivement des élus locaux des
élus d'ailleurs nationaux ça ne change
absolument rien merci beaucoup fabrice
sa division aucun spécialisant la
défense des professionnels de santé
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france après le premier bol d'air d'un
week end est confiné jour de rentrée des
classes pour les collégiens de 6e et 5e
en zone verte exclusivement 185 mille
élèves au total deuxième rentrée après
celle des maternelles et des primaires
lundi dernier et l'on a appris ce matin
que 70 cas de kobe 19 avaient été
détectées dans les écoles depuis le
début du conflit déconfinement le
ministre de l'éducation nationale en a
fait l'annoncé était en visite ce matin
dans l'eure à l'occasion de la
réouverture d'un collège il ya plus de
quarante mille écoles qui ont ouvert en
france sur sur cinquante mille et nous
en a 70 qui ont fermé depuis la semaine
dernière c'est donc un pourcentage très
faible et il faut savoir que c'est dans
une même ville par souvent pas exemple
si vous prenez la ville de sens 25 des
70 dont je vous parle sont dans la même
ville parce qu'il ya eu un cas de kobe
dans cette ville donc il ya si vous
voulez
la nécessité d'être stricte rigoureux et
donc le fait qu'on soit parfois amené à
faire une école ne doit pas inquiéter ça
fait partie au contraire du fait que dès
qu'on a une suspicion mais on est
attentif parce que ça ferme et puis
éventuellement sa ré ouvre une fois que
les choses sont claires une rentrée dans
le respect des protocoles sanitaires
dont comme ici au collège privé saint
joseph dans le gers reportage d'hervé
grand champ avec clément l'hôpital il
est midi et le sel de ce collège du gers
est désertée l'établissement a rouvert
ses portes récemment et doit s'adapter
aux nouvelles directives pour sa rentrée
post confinement c'est désormais dans
leur salle de classe que les élèves
prennent leur repas sains par table est
toujours en respectant les distances de
sécurité
c'est un déjeuner en silence presque
studieux chaque groupe à sa classe avec
sa table et c'est il ya marquage sur
chaque espace et chaque place donc les
avenues classifie avec un espace de
cours dédiés et il n'y a aucun
croisement entre les élèves et les
groupes d'élèves et une autre classe de
ce côté fille sur ce bâtiment avec une
cour de l'autre côté où chaque classe a
son espace est réservé en temps normal
ce collège accueille 300 élèves dont 70
pensionnaires
désormais c'est une quarantaine
d'adolescents qui occupent les lieux
les effectifs des classes ont été
divisées de moitié une table vide ses
parts dès à présent chaque élève de son
voisin une ambiance pesante règne dans
la salle de classe
il est très difficile pour eux de garder
leur masse toute la journée en classe
c'est carrément une torture on est sans
arrêt en train de regarder
ils ont du mal à parler ils ont du mal à
respirer on voit bien que ça l'est ça
les fatigue face est évident et pour
leur permettre de souffler même à
travers leurs masques le collège a mis
en place des cours de sport quotidien
afin que les élèves puissent
dépenser physiquement en toute sécurité
la rentrée des élèves de 6e et 5e des
établissements situés en zone verte
s'est effectuée en toute sérénité ce
lundi en ce qui concerne les collégiens
de 4e et de 3e ainsi que les lycéens
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
devrait se prononcer à la fin du mois de
mai une semaine après le début du
déconfinement les autorités avancent
donc prudemment à tâtons les foyers de
reprise de l'épidémie sont surveillés
comme le lait sur le feu
70 car on disait encore namy meuse dans
les écoles depuis la réouverture la
semaine dernière 25 foyers infectieux
dont plusieurs dans des entreprises
notamment des abattoirs école entreprise
le déconfinement en va-t-il trop vite
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes
avec manon lebreton enseignante de
lettres modernes au collège membres de
l'aider constituant à ses côtés denis
jacquet entrepreneurs président de
l'association parrainé la croissance
auteur de pourquoi votre prochain patron
sera chinois aux éditions eyrolles
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
maintenant le breton vous vous êtes donc
on le disait enseignante en zone verte
vous avez fait la rentrée des des
collèges aujourd'hui comment ça s'est
passé est ce que les protocoles
sanitaires ont été respectées difficile
à mettre en place
alors bon soir d'abord oui je viens de
terminer la première journée en
présentiel comme on dit couramment
maintenant face à mes élèves
enfin mes élèves c'est quand même
beaucoup dire on peut dire que oui les
le protocole a été globalement plutôt
respectée et pour cause puisque nous
avions convoqué aujourd'hui un seul des
quatre niveaux de koleje c'était les
classes de 5e à castelnaudary 2 ans dans
mon collège qui était convoqué on a sur
180 élèves
nous avons accueilli 29 élèves
donc moi j'ai vu deux élèves
dans un groupe et trois élèves dans
l'autre donc en réalité ça fait des
semaines maintenant en fait depuis que
emmanuel macron a sorti du chapeau cette
reprise scolaire à la date du 11 mai que
les chefs d'établissements les élus
locaux les enseignants les parents
d'élèves s'arrache les cheveux à qui
mieux mieux pour essayer de faire la
quadrature du cercle c'est à dire
respecter à la fois le protocole
sanitaire
et puis les exigences pédagogiques
minimale enfin tout ce qui peut donner
le moindre sens à cette reprise est bien
on constate que ça fait donc des
semaines qu'on court après les
informations contradictoires les
annonces dans la presse
très peu d'informations directes en
réalité pour nos directions en
particulier tout ça pour finalement
accueillir
je vous dis deux élèves dans une classe
trois élèves dans l'autre alors
effectivement on a de la place on a de
quoi prendre de l'espace mais je peux
ajouter pour finir que ces élèves là ne
sont pas ceux qui étaient tant réclamé
par jean michel blanquer requis disait
se préoccuper plus que tous des élèves
décrocheurs de ceux qui n'ont pas les
moyens de se connecter etc
il se trouve que moi parmi les élèves
que j'ai vu aujourd'hui je les avais
tous vu presque à chaque connexion en
classe virtuelle lorsque je les avais
mis en place donc ce ne sont pas les
décrocheurs et c'était évident pour
n'importe qui connaît un peu le
fonctionnement de ces élèves là que si
on laisse le choix aux familles je dis
pas qu'on a eu tort de le faire mais en
tout cas c'était clair que ce n'était
pas pour toucher ce public là denis
jacquet vous vous êtes étonnés par ce
que nous raconte manon lebreton une
minorité
élève qui retourne au collège et puis
faire un sentiment un petit peu voilà
tout ça pour ça et que les choses
restent extrêmement compliquées on
aurait peut-être dû attendre septembre
pour vous écouter en fait il ya une
sensation aujourd'hui qu'à force d'avoir
mis les français sous cloche ils
deviennent un peu alors c'est un peu
méchant mais au bout d'un moment il faut
bien reprendre donc pourquoi on peut pas
reprendre plus tard pourquoi c'est mieux
dans quinze jours dans un mois dans
trois mois chaque mois on trouvera une
raison de ne pas reprendre un moment
donné il faut reprendre sa 2 deux ou
trois raisons majeures je le pense je
suis pas médecin 1
si vous regardez quand même sur les 280
mille personnes qui sont mortes dans le
monde chercher les enfants
il y en a très peu donc on sait très
bien qu'aujourd'hui cette maladie ne les
atteint pas peu ou extrêmement
légèrement la deuxième chose c'est qu'à
un moment donné si on veut que
l'économie reparte pas ce que cette
récession elle va être monstrueuse et
elle va être monstrueuse pour qui pour
les plus fragiles pour ceux qui vont
perdre leur emploi pour les
entrepreneurs qui vont faire faillite
qui font déjà faillite mais à un moment
donné il faut que les parents puissent
confier leurs enfants
si on a on va avoir une chance que des
entreprises redémarrent et je vous parle
pas des entreprises du cac40 qu'on veut
toujours flageller mais dont on a
excessivement besoin je vous parle des
petites pme dans tous les territoires et
franchement avoir fait mais comme pour
la crise une telle différenciation entre
le grand est et paris qui était touché
je vous rappelle quand même que dans
plus de 75% des départements on avait
moins dix personnes et pour la majorité
d'entre moins de cinq personnes pour
cent mille qui était dans un lit
d'hôpital
on estime qu'aujourd'hui on est
contaminé à 6% c'est-à-dire que 94 la
pop au sens de la population aujourd'hui
n'est pas touché et on veut nous
expliquer qu'il faudrait pas des confits
n'est pas retournée à l'école pas
retourner travailler
mais en fait le réveil va être
extrêmement brutal c'est ça que je
n'arrive pas à comprendre ses acquis et
personne pour se réveiller dans ce pays
sur deux choses 1
le fait que à part cuba et la corée du
nord on est aujourd'hui dans des pays
dont on ne peut pas sortir les
frontières sont fermées on est confiné
chez soi on doit s'écrire un automoteur
sortir de chez soi en fait je veux dire
c'est du jamais vu depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale qui étaient autrement
plus dangereuse que ce virus est la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on plonge nos
économies dans une récession et c'est
pas pour
leur plaisir aux grandes entreprises
pour qu'elles s'enrichir on va faire des
morts économique des morts de désespoir
des morts de gens qui ne retrouveront
jamais leur emploi demain et c'est ça
que je n'arrive toujours pas à
comprendre aujourd'hui
maintenant nos bretons ça vous choque ce
discours mais il a le mérite de la
clarté parce qu'on a souvent reproché au
gouvernement de ne pas jouer la
franchise en disant vous le faisiez vous
y faisiez mentions vous même tout à
l'heure les décrocheurs leur cabine
arrière pensée économique tout
simplement pour que les parents
retournent travailler
est ce que c'est un discours qui est
tout de même audible pour vous pouvez
comprendre
je crois qu'il ya déjà beaucoup de
choses parfois contradictoires
d'ailleurs le discours du gouvernement
on lui reproche pas son manque de
franchise on lui reproche de dire
absolument tout et son contraire à
chaque fois selon les besoins du moment
donc en réalité plus personne ne prête
sérieusement attention à ce qui est
raconté c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
dramatique pour revenir sur sur ce que
vous venez de me répondre je crois que
d'abord il faut commencer par distinguer
la question du déconfinement et la
question de la reprise de la réouverture
des écoles pour la simple raison que on
l'a on l'a dit répété mais les
protocoles les tous les spécialistes de
ces protocoles de déconfinement les
spécialistes sanitaires scientifiques
disent depuis longtemps que le principe
à suivre dans en cas de déconfinement
c'est con on ré ouvre en dernier
les établissements qui ont fermé en
premier or nous avons commencé par
fermer les établissements scolaires
parce qu'ils étaient potentiellement des
foyers de de diffusion du virus et donc
il aurait dû en toute logique être
remettre en route on parle peu mais j'ai
une question quand même à vous poser il
ya une tribune de d'éminents pédiatre le
chef du service pédiatrie de robert
debré
ils ont publié une pub une tribune la
semaine dernière dans le quotidien du
médecin
appelant les parents à remettre les
enfants à l'école affirmant qu'il n'y
avait absolument aucun danger ni pour
les uns ni pour les autres que les
enfants contaminés qu'on a misé pardon
contaminé l'été par les adultes et pas
l'un vers ce qu'est ce que vous répondez
tout de même alors je vais finir de dire
de répondre à la première chose sûre
c'est la question des tribunaux on en a
tellement en ce moment qu'ils disent là
aussi tout et son contraire que si on
devait caler notre comportement et les
doctrines gouvernementale sur les
tribunes on serait pas sorti de
l'auberge à mon avenir
donc je n'ai pas connaissance de celle
ci en particulier mais ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que en tout cas le
conseil scientifique dont le
gouvernement se réclamer pendant un
certain temps avait comme vous le savez
préconisé un retour en septembre donc
pour vous répondre monsieur ça fait
quand même une raison non négligeable
d'attendre septembre et je parle là de
la réouverture des écoles
vous me répondez que les écoles doivent
rouvrir pour renvoyer les parents au
travail c'est effectivement sans doute
dans cette optique là qu emmanuel macron
à d'emblée associé déconfinement et
réouverture des écoles
sauf que là aussi c'est un échec total
je vous dis que moi aujourd'hui alors
d'une part les élèves
au delà de au dessus de la 4e sont ne
sont il n'est pas question de les faire
revenir au collège pour l'instant donc
qu'en est il de leurs parents je vous
garantis que tous les élèves de
quatrième ne peuvent pas garder tout
seul et par ailleurs moi j'ai reçu je
vous dis aujourd'hui uniquement des
classes de 5e
les élèves ne peuvent pas tous retourner
tous les jours à l'école puisque on fait
des petits groupes et encore heureux
puisque sinon on annulerait totalement
le bénéfice du confinement est donc en
réalité les parents sont de la même
façon confrontés à la difficulté de
faire garder leurs enfants moi pour
l'exemple de mon collège et bien un jour
sur par semaine ils sont pris en charge
quand ils le souhaitent et le résultat
ça n'est pas le cas et ce qu'on constate
de toute façon je voulais dit c'est que
là les normes l'écrasante l'écrasante
majorité des parents ne renvoient pas
leurs enfants à l'école
c'est là aussi quand on l'a vu
au moment des municipales une forme de
grève civique pour moi qui s'exprime de
cette façon là et c'est la défiance
envers la parole gouvernementale et
l'action gouvernementale qui trouve ici
une expression absolument criante et
c'est je le répète vraiment préoccupant
pour l'avenir de notre pays que de voir
à quel point les français n'ont plus
confiance dans l'action du gouvernement
et jaked mais vous faire réagir lorsque
le temps passe sur l'entreprise
également le déconfinement se sait dans
les entreprises également avec un
protocole sanitaire imposée très strict
pour les entreprises vous craignez vous
justement en tant qu'entrepreneur des
mini foyer qui ressurgissent dans des
entreprises au contraire il faut y aller
désormais renvoyer les gens au travail
ils auront du sang sur les mains demain
il faudra qu'ils on assume la
responsabilité
je le répète 280 mille morts sur 7
milliards d'individus
donc on sait pas le choléra c'est pas la
peste c'est par ebola c'est pas qu'on a
connus avant on ne comprend pas pourquoi
pour un taux de mortalité aussi faible
qui ne se remarquera même pas dans les
statistiques dans dix ans on puisse
condamner à mort
économiquement non pas les entreprises
les salariés ceux qui vont perdre leur
job dans les territoires petits et
moyens moi je venais d'un petit
territoire rural avec une ville moyenne
aucun des emplois perdus c'est trente
dernières années ne s'est jamais recréé
on n'a pas une crise de cette nature là
les emplois même dans les terrains
agricoles pour faire des mauvais john
mcdonough de l'engrais ça ne repousse
pas moi où j'ai vécu toute ma vie toute
mon enfance tous les emplois perdus ces
trente dernières années n'ont disparu
mais vous savez qui est le principal
employeur aujourd'hui de la ville de
naissance c'est l'hôpital donc il faut
un moment donné comprendre que est-ce
que vous avez vu les les exemplaires et
là je rejoins madame sur la question de
la défiance ce gouvernement est un des
pires sur la gestion de la crise dans le
monde
voilà je veux dire les choses sont
extrêmement claires quand j'entends
castaner nous donner des leçons sur la
responsabilité lui qui apparaissait dans
des vidéos sur youtube
éméché avec sa maîtresse au no tô il ya
quelques mois paris
me fait rigoler et ces gens-là nous
donne des leçons on n'a pas de masque
tout le monde savait même quelqu'un qui
n'est pas médecin que les masques
étaient la clé hong kong taiwan du
vietnam moins 200 morts chacun pourquoi
parce que les gens portaient des masques
et ne peuvent pas infecter les autres
aujourd'hui on soit dans nos entreprises
des guides de 40 50 80 pages pour nous
expliquer comment réaffecter un espace
et ne pas et maintenir la distanciation
on a deux millions d'entreprises de
moins de 10 personnes
elles ont 80 mètres carrés de locaux
vous faites comment pour faire du
télétravail pour ses boîtes là vous
faites comment pour les faire revenir
cette maladie ne tue pas ce qui a tué
s'est lentement d'organisation 25000 25
millions en allemagne
cinq mille en france ce qui a tué les
gens c'est que le système de santé et
soit en faillite
on les a abandonnés depuis 30 ans et
qu'on ne puisse pas accueillir les gens
dans de bonnes conditions
si on avait les lie le personnel les
équipements aujourd'hui une partie des
gens qui sont décédés aujourd'hui ne
serait pas mort et franchement ne pas
renvoyer à l'école dans les entreprises
dans des zones où je vous le rappelle en
france dont 70 % des départements je le
répète il y a moins de cinq personnes
pour cent mille dans un lit d'hôpital
c'est juste une catastrophe donc pensé
pour une fois oublié paris pensé à la
province penser au petit territoire
ils sont en train de mourir quand un
entrepreneur moeurs ce sont quatre cinq
ou dix salariés qui meurt et qu'ils ne
retrouveront jamais leur emploi donc
qu'on m'explique que c'est pas bien de
les confiner comme ça qu'on peut pas
faire confiance au gouvernement qu
aujourd'hui j'ai reçu que cinq ou dix
élèves très bien mais c'est quoi la
solution d'attendre le mois prochain
pourquoi ça sera mieux le mois prochain
et pourquoi pas mieux le mois d'après il
faut bien démarrer un moment donné on a
compris lorsque vous faire réagir sur un
autre point et vous faites des réponses
très longue tous les deux donc c'est un
peu compliqué répondait rapidement s'il
vous plaît oui non mais j'en doute
je pense que là où seront d'accord c'est
que le bon moment pour le déconfinement
c'est toujours le plus tôt possible pour
vous comme pour moi et moi j'ai hâte de
pouvoir retrouver mes élèves dans des
conditions qui s'y prêtent
la question c'est qu'est ce qui permet
un des continents dans de bonnes
conditions
or à l'heure actuelle nous n'avons pas
avancé sur ce point là
je repense aux annonces de olivier
ferrand qui nous disait il ya quelques
semaines que pour permettre un
déconfinement dans de bonnes conditions
nous allions augmenter progressivement
la quantité de tests effectués et qu'on
allait augmenter la capacité à 700 mille
tests par semaine aujourd'hui le
déconfinement a commencé depuis une
semaine et on est très très loin
puisqu'on est à peine à la moitié de ce
qui a été annoncé dans les derniers
chiffres qu'il a donnée autrement dit on
ne se donne pas les moyens de de
permettre à se découvrir confinement
d'avoir lieu en laissant en mettant les
français en sécurité et ils sentent
cette insécurité et c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont extrêmement réticents à y aller et
je pense que de toute façon tout le
monde conviendra aussi que l'économie
elle est une problématique primordial
pour tout le monde mais que ça ne
servira à rien de descons fine et
n'importe comment et de devoirs confinés
dans deux semaines ou un mois
voilà merci merci à tous les deux mais
non à lebreton enseignante donc denis
jacquet entre 20h d'avoir été avec nous
pour débattre sur ce déconfinement merci
à vous et à moi présent sur le bilan de
l'épidémie de coronavirus dans
l'hexagone on compte plus de 28 mille
décès selon elle les chiffres de la
direction générale de la santé cent
trente et une personnes sont mortes en
24 heures le nombre de personnes en
réanimation continue de baisser et passe
sous la barre des 2000 patients le solde
est négatif comme depuis début avril de
89 malades
les chiffres rassurants donc malgré le
recensement de nouveaux foyers
l'annnonce de 54 cas positifs dans un
abattoir de la commune où les dépistages
de salariés se poursuivre
deux autres abattoirs en vendée dans les
côtes d'armor ont également recensé des
foyers de contamination
au total plus de cent cas alors pourquoi
les abattoirs sont ils être des foyers
de contamination à haut risque éléments
de réponse
et
[Musique]
c'est
il n'ya pas de chaîne de contamination
prouver à partir de la viande ou de
l'ingestion de viande
ce n'est pas le mode de transmission du
virus on est vraiment sûr de la
contamination attaques personnelles des
salariés entre eux et c'est donc cette
chaîne de contamination qu'on essaie de
stopper en recherchant tous les cas
contact des personnes contaminées
[Musique]
et bonne nouvelle à présent en italie le
bilan quotidien passe sous la barre des
100 décès plus 99 morts lors de ces
dernières 24 heures les italiens qui
avancent petit à petit vers un retour à
la normale
la phase 2 du plan de déconfinement est
entrée en vigueur ce lundi commerces
restaurants et cafés ont rouvert tout
comme les lieux de culte quentin
mauclair des clients assis en terrasse
une image que l'on n'avait plus
l'habitude de voir ces derniers mois
premier pays européen touché par le
coronavirus l'italie se relève peu à peu
ce lundi le plan de déconfinement est
entré dans sa deuxième phase
les restaurants bars et commerces
peuvent de nouveau accueillir du public
la confédération patronale comptes
commerciaux estiment que près de 800000
commerce sont en principe concernées par
la reprise d'activité comme ici à rome
les serveurs masqué attentes des clients
mais ils sont peu nombreux à s'asseoir
pour profiter d'un café ou d'un plat
maintenant quoi nous nous sentons
presque ému car cela fait deux mois que
nous ne sommes pas allés manger au
restaurant et je vous dirai ce que nous
en pensons dès que nous aurons fini de
manger mais ce n'est pas pareil nous
sommes assis loin l'un de l'autre
nous devons parler plus fort donc on va
faire plus de bruit autre symbole du
retour progressif à la normale les lieux
de culte ont eux aussi rouvert leurs
portes au public le duomo de milan a
accueilli ses fidèles tout en appliquant
les mesures strictes en vigueur
désinfection des mains port du masque
nombre de personnes limitées à
l'intérieur et distanciation physique
au vatican le pape françois a célébré
une messe à la basilique saint pierre
il en va de même à rome où ce prêtre
était satisfait de pouvoir tenir un
office après deux mois de confinement
ceci est je pense qu'il était très sage
de reprendre les metz lundi afin que
nous puissions aussi voir un peu comment
les fidèles se comportent les petites
choses à mettre en place
c'est une sorte de répétition générale
avant le grand jour que sera dimanche
tél
de son côté le gouvernement veut éviter
une deuxième vague
la prudence est de mise malgré le besoin
urgent de relancer l'activité économique
wald athenes les blinch ibm en lice
laisse nos principes restent les mêmes
ce sont nos valeurs
il s'agit en premier lieu de protéger la
vie la santé des citoyens
ces principes ces valeurs sont non
négociables mais nous devons les
appliquer de façon spécifique durant
cette deuxième phase nous ne pouvons pas
nous permettre d'attendre la découverte
et la distribution d'un vaccin
nous nous retrouverions alors avec un
outil productif et un contexte social
fortement dégradé forte dans la vie
reprend progressivement son cours en
italie
la prochaine étape du déconfinement
amènera la réouverture des gymnases
piscines et centres sportifs
cette nouvelle étape est annoncée pour
le 25 mai prochain la belle j'y passe au
stade 2 de sons déconfinement
aujourd'hui des écoles reprennent
progressivement sauf pour les classes
maternelles est les commerçants comme
les coiffeurs ou esthéticiennes peuvent
désormais accueillir des clients
idem pour les musées parcs animaliers
certains bâtiments historiques ou encore
lé marché est limité à 50 commerçants
enfin les entraînements sportifs en
extérieur sont autorisés avec 20
personnes maximum la communauté
éducative se félicite de cette
réouverture des classes pour les 6e
primaire tout a été organisé de sorte
qu'ils aient des entrées des points
d'entrée différents dans l'école et
qu'ils aient leur propre itinéraire de
passage pour arriver dans leurs locaux
les locaux ont été organisées de sorte
qu'il y ait bien quatre mètres carrés
par enfant et oui m² pour l'enseignant
je suis convaincu qu'au niveau social et
au niveau psychologique c'était
important que les enfants aient un
contact entre eux et avec l'institution
avec leur institutrice leur instituteur
reprendre contact c'est absolument
indispensable mais le royaume-uni
enregistré une baisse de mort record
depuis mars 170 morts en 24 heures
longues qui souhaite débloquer 94
millions d'euros pour soutenir la
recherche
une enveloppe qui s'ajoutent aux 50 3
millions déjà investis par le
gouvernement britannique auprès de
l'université d'oxford et de l'impérial
collège de la capitale
les recherches pour trouver un vaccin
contre le coc vie 19 qui ont commencé le
mois dernier et le déconfinement
commence hongrie les habitants de
budapest ont pu sortir de chez eux
aujourd'hui après deux mois et demi de
restriction la hongrie compte
officiellement 3535 car de kobe de 19 et
462 morts du virus
les habitants de la capitale hongroise
ont exprimé leur joie de pouvoir se
déplacer librement
je suis vraiment heureuse que les
restrictions à t khd je vais pouvoir
acheter ce dont j'ai besoin
il ya de bons et de mauvais aspects
connaissant les gens ici je pense que ça
ira avec un sentiment de grande
libération et de rassemblements de masse
il y aura peut-être aussi le saut
d'irresponsabilité qui sait
[Applaudissements]
la russie devient le deuxième pays le
plus touché dans le monde derrière les
etats-unis elle dénombre plus de 290000
contamination le nombre de décès dépasse
les 2700 une situation compliquée mais
qui se stabilise selon lagence net
sanitaire russe
on retrouve en direct à moscou notre
correspondant antoine claireaux bonsoir
antoine les derniers chiffres publiés
par les autorités sont encourageants le
pic de l'épidémie at il été franchie
mais on dirait bien que la courbe
commence à s'inverser c'est en tout cas
ce que les chiffres montrent un peu
moins de 9000 nouveaux cas ont été
enregistrés ces dernières 24 heures soit
le total le plus faible depuis le 1er
mai le premier ministre en a profité
pour faire le point je vous propose de
l'écouter la situation quant à la
propagation du court aux navires us de
notre pays reste difficile mais on peut
tout de même dire que la croissance de
la maladie a été arrêté selon les
estimations les plus prudentes
la dynamique est positive de plus en
plus de personnes seraient abysses et
quitte les hôpitaux
nous y voyons le résultat du travail
mené de manière 6
matic en russie depuis ces deux derniers
mois le confinement strict a joué son
rôle nous a permis de gagner du temps
ils de prévenir une croissance explosive
de la maladie comme ça a été le cas dans
plusieurs pays
alors c'est vrai les chiffres officiels
sont parfois contestées le maire de la
capitale lui même admet que la
proportion de la population touchée par
le coronavirus pourrait être plus
importante que ce que disent les chiens
et c'est pour cette raison afin d'avoir
une idée la plus fidèle possible de la
réalité que sa graisse sobianine annoncé
que tous les moscovites qui le
souhaitent pourraient se faire dépister
dans un délai de deux à trois semaines
ici la fin du mois moscou aura donc la
capacité de tester plus de deux cent
mille personnes par jour d'ailleurs le
confinement est toujours de mise en
particulier dans la capitale principal
foyer de la pandémie qui recense près de
la moitié des cas déclare le port du
masque et de gants est obligatoire dans
les transports en commun ou encore pour
faire ses courses
alors bien sûr il est toujours délicat
de parler avec certitude du nombre de
morts ou du nombre de contaminés mais au
delà des chiffres ce qui est important
c'est de dégager une tendance
et aujourd'hui cette tendance semble
être à la baisse merci antoine frérot
notre correspondant à moscou et les
etats-unis restent le foyer mondial de
la pandémie les conséquences économiques
y sont dramatiques
le taux de chômage pourrait atteindre 20
à 25% selon le patron de la banque
centrale américaine
une reprise est envisagée à partir du
troisième trimestre 2000 20 mai c'est
certain la crise sanitaire devrait
laisser des traces on voit cela en
images
[Musique]
on
oh
[Musique]
où
oh
[Musique]
et dans le reste de l'actualité en
france ces violences l'ennemi dernière
argentin des échauffourées à la suite de
la mort d'un jeune homme à moto dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche le parquet de
pontoise affirme que les policiers ne
poursuivez pas le jeune homme mais la
famille et les proches de sabri accusent
les forces de l'ordre présentes sur
place d'être en cause dans l'accident
nicolas bean clair avec thomas bonnet
haïk se sont rendus sur place
c'est une famille meurtrie qui nous a
ouvert ses portes
les proches du jeune sabri décédé à
l'âge de 18 ans vivent une peine immense
ils souhaitent comprendre ce qui a pu se
passer ce soir là c'est pas à écrire
comme ça et j'en suis sûr donc voilà je
connaître qu'est ce qui s'est passé rêve
moi ce que je demande - moi je sais pas
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce que je sais
c'est que j'ai perdu beaucoup à mon fils
16 c1 c'est le chef et les chefs ces
annonces un amour j'ai perdu je fais
confiance à la justice à la loi voilà
j'attends la réponse
nous voilà la mort de ce jeune homme
décrit comme souriant et sans histoires
bouleverse les habitants de ce quartier
d'argenteuil ce qui accentue cette
émotion c'est le flou qui entoure les
circonstances de la mort du jeune homme
les faits se sont déroulés dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche dans un quartier
pavillonnaire de la ville à bord d'une
moto sans casque sabri a perdu la vie au
moment des faits une voiture de la
brigade anticriminalité est présente
près des lieux mais selon les éléments
dévoilés ce lundi par le parquet de
pontoise le jeune motocycliste n'étaient
pas poursuivis par la voiture de police
présentes à proximité
une version que réfute les proches de
sabri sabri aurait percuté
ce poteau voiture et elle serait mort à
l'hôpital
nous on n'y croit pas du tout on ne
croit pas du tout certains voisins
auraient entendu un bruit par shop
nous on est persuadé que c'est une
bavure et voilà on veut juste que
justice soit faite
dans le quartier où vivait sabri la
colère est forte mais face aux images de
violences qui ont émaillé la commune
d'argenteuil
la famille du jeune homme appelle au
calme et à l'apaisement deux avocates
ont été choisis pour s'occuper du
dossier
une marche en mémoire de sabri aura lieu
mercredi à 15 heures dans la ville
d'argentan et pour en parler nous sommes
avec christophe crépin porte parole du
syndicat france police bonsoir
christophe crépin merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france deux versions
d'un accident de la route qui s'opposent
comme souvent dans ce genre d'affaires
c'est inéluctable systématiquement quand
il ya une problématique
déjà c'est très triste la mort de ce
jeune homme est très triste et
systématiquement mes collègues font
preuve de la présomption de culpabilité
pendant que d'après les premières
constatations il n'y a eu aucun contrôle
ni aucun choc avec la voiture de police
donc qu'on va attendre les résultats de
l'enquêté
et on va bien voir comment ça se passe
mais rien ne peut justifier de telles
violences urbaines dans un quartier
suite à la mort de ce pauvre jeune homme
alors que sait-on exactement de cet
accident pour l'heure qui a coûté la vie
comme on dit à ce jeune homme on sait
qu'il circulait avec une moto cross que
il a perdu le contrôle de son véhicule
qui est venu s'encastrer malheureusement
dans un poteau téléphonique en ciment et
suite au choc il a été transporté à
l'hôpital où il est décédé
je comprends très bien le deuil de cette
famille je comprends très bien également
le fait que ces gens veulent savoir et
c'est normal quand on perd approche
comme ça surtout un jeune de 18 ans
c'est triste mais rien ne peut justifier
de telles violences urbaines
argenteuil d'ailleurs la famille et nous
mêmes nous nous vendons que toussaint
cesse alors le parquet de pontoise un
écarte à ce jour l'hypothèse d'un
contact vous l'avez dit vous-même entre
la moto et la voiture de la bac est ce
que ce n'est pas trop tôt pour tirer ce
genre de bilan est ce qu'il ya une
enquête sérieuse de fait deux ans
qu'elle est la première à administrative
le deuxième judiciaire systématiquement
quand les fonctionnaires sont rentrés au
service on a pu déterminer qui a pas eu
de choc avec le véhicule administratif
ça c'est une chose
et deuxièmement le parquet a ouvert une
enquête et il a fait au maximum
rapidement pour pouvoir déterminer si
les fonctionnaires peuvent être
incriminé ou non est a priori les
résultats du parquet sont claires et
nettes
faut-il craindre selon vous de nouvelles
tensions vont tant que policiers
voulaient craignais on sait déjà que
c'est extrêmement tendue sur le terrain
notamment pendant la période de
confinement on en a beaucoup parlé ici
alors tu te fais pendant la période
confirme on a eu beaucoup de mérite
urbaine systématiquement dès qu'il y
avait une petite chose ça partait tout
de suite tout de suite en exactions des
banlieues entières s'enflammait là
j'espère car gentric vince calmer parce
que rien ne pourra faire ramener le
jeune homme et moi j'en appelle à une
chose qui est très importante c'est que
systématiquement mes collègues sont
vraiment bénéficié la suspicion de
suspicion et de la présomption de
culpabilité non pas d'innocence est ce
que vous pensez justement que ces
tensions font suite également à celles
qui se sont déroulées à villeneuve la
garenne également après un accident de
moto en quelque sorte l'attention des
professeurs une moto qui ne devait pas
circuler les gens appellent la police
les legends est excédé par le bruit par
les nuisances appelle mes collègues mes
collègues essaye de procéder à une
interpellation
et quand ils vont procéder à
l'interpellation ce jeune homme vers
s'encastrer dans une dans une espèce de
bronze but en béton il essaye de lui
porter secours étaient systématiquement
sa part tout de suite en présomption de
culpabilité
comment justement vous expliquer cela
vous en avait parlé en début de cette
interview une femme de présomption de
culpabilité il y aurait les bons d'un
côté les méchants de l'autre on imagine
que c'est évidemment beaucoup plus
complexe que cela
ne riez pas des bons n'ya pas de
méchants il ya des gens qui vivent dans
des banlieues et des gens qui veulent
vivre correctement
et puis à des aviateurs ya des gens qui
sont là pour créer des nuisances il ya
des gens qui vont qui qui essayent de
sortir les banlieues pour en faire des
belles choses et je pense que les
violences urbaines que kiki qui font
jour aujourd'hui ne peuvent rien
apporter surtout danser dans cette
situation qui est très difficile
aujourd'hui clairement christophe crépin
au sein de votre syndicat quelles
seraient les solutions les idées que
vous souhaiteriez apporter pour apaiser
les tensions constamment sur le terrain
qui doivent être compliqué pour les
policiers on imagine aussi des déjà il
est
les nounous personnellement on
s'explique toujours avec secrétaire
l'été avec le musée intérieur où il ya
fait des propositions ces provisions
n'ont jamais encore pour l'instant été
suivies d'effet je pense qu'il faut rien
laisser passer
et il faut essayer de renouer le lien
entre la population qui habite dans ces
banlieues qui elle rend au respect et
les individus qui crée des nuisances
merci beaucoup christophe crépin porte
parole du syndicat france police d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
après ces nouvelles tensions la nuit
dernière à argenteuil rester avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons du
secteur hospitalier nouveau olivier
verront réunira le 25 mai les
partenaires sociaux et les collectifs
hospitalier pour donner le coup d'envoi
ségur de la santé et puis direction
l'assemblée nationale qui verra demain à
la création d'un nouveau groupe
parlementaire baptisé écologie
démocratie et solidarité
le groupe la république en marche vers 1
6 la majorité absolue rester avec nous
sur rt france
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et d'un fonds talents de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
gata ce trop fine il ya un tournant et
on refermait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais une décision à vraisemblable
pour vous ça dépend telles valeurs on
attribuait la mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
morales un débat éthique
[Musique]
est ce qu'on sait combien d'enfants sont
victimes de ces violences et qui sont
concernés par ces drames qui se déroule
dans le huis clos familial pendant la
période actuelle il est difficile de
dire précisément combien d'enfants sont
concernés car en fait on a très peu de
visibilité
nous savons simplement que il y à des
situations effectivement qui s'aggrave
dans les familles il ya toutes les
classes sociales qui sont concernés par
la maltraitance il faut qu'on le dise
ils redisent là le problème c'est que
dans le cas du confinement il ya plus
cet entourage et tout se fait à distance
ce qui fait qu'il est très difficile de
repérer par téléphone par visiophone ces
situations et notre inquiétude un porte
plutôt sur ce que nous voyons pas la
partie immergée de l'iceberg en fait
parce que les très difficile pour les
enfants malgré tout d'aller le même
et dans ce cas là on n'entend rien ça se
fait totalement dans le silence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons on est dans une
espèce de déni collectif on ne veut pas
croire ce qu'on sait et scientifique
parle quand même de la sixième
extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
et à d'autres experts qui contestent
leur six personnes non non c'est pas
vrai il ya des climats tout c'est
maintenant et non ce n'est pas rien à
part il ya des gens qui ne sont pas des
chercheurs qui parlent que la presse met
en avant parce que il faut que du débat
mais il ya plus de débat aujourd'hui il
n'y a plus aucun débat ce changement
climatique et on va vers un vrai par une
catastrophe ou 20 vers une vraie
catastrophe et on est incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas des pessimistes de
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et les demies il
n'a pas d'ennemi l'ennemi ceni
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les coups sont permis la stratégie
de conquête de marchés à l'exportation
s'appuie sur une politique offensive de
pillages deux fleurons du secteur
stratégique
le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
en jouant sur quatre critères clés
l'argent l'idéologie légaux et la
compromission
ce phénomène il est mondial on le
retrouve partout
c'est pourquoi on est frappé par la
naïveté des personnels et d'encadrement
à ce type de prat une existe sur la
planète pour beaucoup d'acteurs tchéquie
et sans aucune hésitation ni morale
la fin justifie les
[Musique]
l'afrique qui compte 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'hérault pour les
états unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus on a proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population ça l'est
beaucoup plus facilement puisqu'elle
venait de sortir d'une d'une épidémie à
ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains si
on aura affaire à deux épidémies aussi
dangereuse qui est des mollahs et
coronavirus ça pourrait être très très
difficile pour
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
et
oh
depuis le début de cette crise les
français sont sont dans le flou avec des
informations contradictoires
quelles en sont les conséquences
psychologiquement la peur quand même
socio économique c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même une détresse socio économique
très très fortes notamment pour pour les
actifs bien évidemment plus vous êtes
âgé plus vous avez peur du réel de la
mort c'est évident ces études
elle montre que oui pourquoi 30 à 40%
il y à un stress modéré il ya un stress
sévère pour à peu près 5%
on a un focus assez fort sur les
adolescents étonnamment un focus sur les
aînés également très important c'est à
dire que ceux qui résisteront le mieux
ce sont entre guillemets la classe d
actifs
est-ce que selon vous l'être humain peut
gérer une proximité quotidienne avec sa
famille comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça resserre les liens vous
contraire est-ce que ça les haltères
nous devons réapprendre le goût du
comportement collectif voilà le goût un
peu d' une autodiscipline le goût du
civisme parce que si nous vivons ça
simplement comme une restriction de nos
libertés individuelles comme si nous ne
vivons pas ça comme une aventure
collective de protection solidaire des
ans a été jeune
ça va être la extraordinairement
[Musique]
mené
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 18 mai l'hôpital en première ligne
dans la crise du coronavirus le secteur
attend beaucoup des négociations qui
débuteront le 25 mai avec le
gouvernement pour un ségur de la santé
une promesse faite par emmanuel macron
au plus fort de l'épidémie de
coronavirus 35 heures augmentation des
salaires après les annonces l'hôpital
attend du concret ni dans la majorité ni
dans l'opposition la journée de mardi
devrait être marquée par la création
d'un nouveau groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale le 9e baptisé
écologie démocratie solidarité il est
notamment composé d'anciens marcheurs
qui ont claqué la porte et devrait faire
perdre sa majorité absolue à la
république en marche
un fonds de solidarité européen de 500
milliards d'euros voilà l'initiative
germano française emmanuel macron et
angela merkel en ont fait l'annoncé cet
après midi objectif investir dans la
protection sanitaire et la transition
écologique avec en toile de fond la
souveraineté économique conséquence le
dax et le cac 40 clôture en hausse ce
soir
[Musique]
la chine s'est dite favorable à une
enquête sur l'origine de l'épidémie une
fois qu'elle sera enrayée
une déclaration du leader chinois xi
jingping à l'occasion de l'assemblée
annuelle de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé une réunion sous tension
les etats unis accusent pékin d'être
responsable de la pandémie
[Musique]
et un mot tout d'abord sur le bilan de
l'épidémie de coronavirus en france on
compte plus de 28 mille décès au total
selon les chiffres de la direction
générale de la santé cent trente et une
personnes sont mortes en 24 heures le
nombre de personnes en réanimation
continue de baisser et passe sous la
barre des 2000 patients le solde est
donc négatif comme depuis comme depuis
début avril de 89 malades le personnel
hospitalier et attend des réponses
concrètes de la part du gouvernement m
malgré les annonces du premier ministre
et du ministre de la santé ce week-end
la volonté du gouvernement d'instaurer
un ségur de la santé les syndicats des
milieux hospitaliers maintiennent la
menace d'une mobilisation le 16 juin à
créteil aujourd'hui les dizaines de
soignants ont manifesté leur
mécontentement écouter on a vécu des
moments hyper difficile pendant la
période covin là ça va un peu mieux mais
on est on
on nous a envoyé des renforts des gens
qui étaient pauvres
et alors
donc ça a été très très difficile
pendant un moment et là aujourd'hui
montre qu'on est mécontent de ce qui
s'est passé et que si on avait eu plus
de l'île de ré a sans doute pu me passer
comme en allemagne
voilà c'est l'heure des comptes et c'est
l'heure de relancer leurs revendications
il y aura peut-être des prochainement d
les mobilisations nous nos
revendications n'ont pas changé c'est
une augmentation salariale que nous
problème à balma chrome on attend de
voir concerner tout le monde
c'est à dire tous les professionnels pas
que les soignants à l'hôpital
illégalement des administratifs et des
services techniques qui sont très
souvent oublié on veut également des
embauches on travaille à un
sous-effectif depuis trop d'années et on
veut des budgets hospitaliers à la
hauteur des besoins de la population
puisque on supprime depuis des années
des milliers de vie et qu'on n'arrive
plus au bois répondent aux besoins de la
population et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct avec erika tricot infirmier
anesthésiste à l'hôpital henri mondor de
créteil syndicat sud-santé bonsoir
hérite que tricot merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france vous avez
participé à la manifestion de
manifestations aujourd'hui que demandez
vous concrètement j'ai surtout
participer j'ai surtout accompagner les
personnels doré inquiété effectivement
en colère qui sont désabusés pour
certains qui ont été humiliés par un
mépris de ce gouvernement
nous ce qu'on demande c'est de répondre
positivement aux trois revendications
qui sont ils nous ont motivés depuis
maintenant six ans un certain nombre de
mois pour ne pas dire un certain nombre
d'années c'était une augmentation et un
recrue de poids hauteur des besoins en
temps personnel mais aussi en moyens
matériels et qui surtout une
revalorisation salariale sur des
salaires qui sont violées depuis trop
longtemps
olivier et veyran a présenté les axes de
son plan il ya des mesures qui semblent
être retenu les augmentations de
salaires pour les personnels soignants
le plan d'investissement et la remise en
question des 35 heures ça c'est un autre
sujet on en parlera il ya des choses
quand même là dedans pipe à vous
rassurer
absolument pas et absolument pas parce
que jusqu'à présent c'est une ce ne sont
que des promesses
ces ondées contre on a l'impression que
le gouvernement découvre la
problématique dans les hôpitaux publics
c'est quand même assez hallucinant alors
moi j'entends les rémunérations
augmentation de l'année des salaires
très bien mais à quelle hauteur je vous
rappelle quand même que monsieur les
rangs à communiquer dans le journal du
dimanche ce week-end bon bilan qu'ont
ils allaient se baser sur la moyenne
européenne à la moyenne européenne que
l'on peut vaincre on n'arrête pas de
dire que
il est pour les premiers de cordée nous
sommes les premiers de cordée
actuellement nous sommes nous avons été
applaudi par des milliers de gens par
des millions de français nous estimons
être les premiers de cordée mais il faut
pas nous mettre à la moyenne de l'europe
avec largement au dessus je rappelle
quand même que nous sommes actuellement
un des meilleurs sans système de santé
au monde et pourtant le personnel
soignant et payer et payer de façon
complètement dérisoires et indécentes
puisque nous sommes 26e sur 20 heures
payées au niveau du classement ocde
quand vous dites on est l'un des
meilleurs santé au monde est ce que
c'est un postulat qui est toujours
valable est ce que cette liste du commis
19 n'a pas démontré que ce n'était plus
le cas
mais moi je crois qu'au contraire elle a
démontré la solidarité entre différents
corps de métier qui a fait justement
face un système de santé que l'on sent
bien qu'ils que ces gouvernements tant
celui de macron que celui de hollande
tend vers une privatisation à outrance
si la solidarité envers comment de tous
ces corps de métiers n'avait pas
fonctionné correctement
ça aurait été une catastrophe sanitaire
et la preuve c'est que monsieur les
rangs et d'autres communicants de ce
gouvernement hollandais on est passé
très près de la catastrophe sanitaire et
cette catastrophe sanitaire elle a été
déjoué parce que justement les
personnels ont remonté les manches et on
sait ils ont fait front sauf que je
rappelle quand même que le président
c'est le chef suprême des forces armées
en france lui il a envoyé son élite
militaire à savoir les personnels
soignants il est envoyé au front sans
moyens de protection ça ça a été
inaccessible il acceptable ce qui fait
de mettre la goutte et le feu aux
poudres
là il vient à la salpêtrière pour offrir
quoi pour nous dire on va vous remettre
une médaille et c'est dû il se situe du
monde sait y mettre
finalement lors leurs propositions qui
seront cédés pansement sur une jambe de
bois
alors moi j'attends ce jeu pour
l'instant j'en aurais rien voir venir je
rappelle quand même que toutes les
primes trou était fait des promises en
tout cas par ce gouvernement on n'en
voit pas la queue on en voit rien du
tout moi je suis excessivement mission
et je vais de toute façon on va de
surprise en mauvaise surprise des
surprises avec ce gouvernement
alors olivier ferrand qui est évoqué les
35 heures aujourd'hui avec leur remise
en cause on sait très bien que vous
travaillez dans les hôpitaux plus que 35
heures quelle est votre réaction par
rapport à cette proposition en tout cas
de les remettre en cause des 35 heures
écoutez je vais assumer ce que je vais
bien
jusqu'à présent les gouvernements quand
ils veulent faire passer une loi alors
que toute l'opinion publique se lève ils
la font passer en force avec le 49-3 moi
j'ai ce sentiment amer mais je ne suis
pas le seul on est tous à avoir ce
sentiment et quand je dis tous c'est
tous les personnels hospitaliers aussi
bien le personnel paramédical que le
personnel médical
on a l'impression qu'ils se servent du
cas du communisme voyage on disait ça
ironiquement taser il ya les
gouvernements et edouard philippe s'en
est servi du 49 3 maintenant ils ont
l'horizon le communisme c'est
hallucinant dans un sort à corps de
métier qui a autant donner pendant deux
mois qui s'est excusé en a quand même
des collègues qui en sont morts et là il
nourrit nous dise bah écoute et on va se
baser sur l'allemagne et travaillent
effectivement ils ont des meilleurs
salaires que goût mais travaille plus
donc on va vous remettre à des taux
horaires au lieu de en bas à nivelles et
les 35 heures non non si on joue
correctement le jeu les 35 heures et
sida les embauches derrière il ya
suffisamment de quoi faire il ya
suffisamment de d'ouverture pour laisser
des 35 heures est embauchée sauf que
c'est une stratégie politique il faut
les chercher des milliards dans les
paradis 6o dans les paradis fixe au
pardon mais c'est aussi de ses voeux
c'est aussi la peau sur la grosse
fortune comme par exemple on n'entend
jamais parler
il ya des milliards en france ils ne
sont pas remis dans l'est dans les
endroits stratégiques que sont les
services publics et là en l'occurrence
l'hôpital public non il ya une autre
stratégie qui est ni plus ni moins que
donner de l'argent par départ des
dividendes et par l'électro patron
d'école 40
dernière question la france pourra
recourir au plan de relance européen
pour rénover l'hôpital c'est bruno le
maire qui le dis ce soir ça pourrait
quand même on a bien compris que vous et
padoue confiance du tout gouvernement
mais ce que ça serait de nature à vous
rassurer
tout de même que ça passe par l'europe
honnêtement je suis là je suis je suis
pas sûr que de passer par l'europe ça
soit une si bonne une si bonne chose
après voilà ça n'engage que moi mais je
sais pas quand je vois certains pays
comme la grèce qui ont été mis à trépas
et c'est l'europe qui est un spéculer
derrière est-ce que derrière il ya un
repas des spéculations sans système de
santé et sur la sécurité sociale voyez
toutes les grains sont qu' il y aura il
ya des interrogations il ya des craintes
du personnel soignant mais aussi par des
politiques qui ont qui ont besoin et
qu'ils ont en tout cas qui vont oeuvrer
pour que le service public et l'hôpital
public re est un joyau de notre
institution donc voyons voir attendons
regardons mais avec la plus grande
vigilance et la plus grande méfiance en
tout cas ça c'est une certitude
et vous l'avez dit en introduction il ya
une date pour la franquette arrêté
qu'elle nous a joints quoi qu'il arrive
plan d'urgence ou pas sanitaires on ira
dans la rue et on ira faire du bruit on
ira chercher notre dû là maintenant
monsieur macron doit se rend bien compte
qu'il ya quand même toute la classe
populaire et tout nice où les projets
qui sont derrière les personnels
soignants on a touché du doigt cette
défaillance du système française
sanitaire et ben maintenant un oud
à nous d'être les premiers de cordée et
nous sommes les premiers deux camps
merci electrico d'avoir été avec nous en
direct les nonces de la création d'un
neuvième groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale ça aura lieu
demain lors d'une vidéoconférence
il sera composé de dissidents la
république en marge tels que cédric
villani au matthieu orphelin les
critiques à leur encontre se multiplient
au sein de la majorité et la pression
commence à s'accentuer sur ces
parlementaires les explications en
images
[Musique]
[Rires]
on
[Musique]
un nouveau groupe à l'assemblée
nationale devrait donc voir le jour
demain jusqu'où le groupe de la majorité
peut-il s'effriter c'est l'objet de
notre face à face prêt pour en débattre
nous sommes avec arnaud benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire à ses côtés par skype
évidemment sébastien ferjou fondateur du
site atlantico bonsoir à tous les deux
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france un neuvième groupe donc l
assemblée écologie démocratie solidarité
ça veut dire une perte de majorité
absolue a plus que six sièges en du
seuil fatidique pour la république en
marche telle conséquence concrète pour
le napperon comprennent un os benedetti
ça signifie sur le plan de
l'arithmétique parlementaire comme vous
l'avez dit que le groupe majoritaire est
que la majorité que le gouvernement
devra négocier
disons de manière régulière avec un
ensemble des autres groupes qui
constituent la kz majoritaire le modem
notamment qui voit son poids politique
en l'occurrence augmenté du fait de
cette défection vers la gauche d'un
certain nombre de parlementaires de la
république en marche mais il faut
s'interroger c'est savoir si on est au
début d'un processus de désagrégation
progressif de la majorité qui mettrait
en péril même la survie de
parlementaires de cette majorité où ils
savent où sont âgés rétine d'une forme
de voir formatage ou de relookages de
cette majorité avec une aile gauche qui
viendrait d'une certaine manière
redonner une identité
on peut plus à gauche à la république en
marche
c'est une question que l'on peut se
poser et que l'on pourra avéré sable
aurait véritablement il lucide et au
cours des semaines et des mois qui
viennent
sébastien ferjou un nominé tétine ou dit
voilà la majorité va devoir composer ce
que ça veut dire si on poursuit leur
jusqu'au bout que le gouvernement va
d'une certaine manière devoir infléchir
sa ligne
je ne crois pas que les gouvernements
particulièrement à composer avec ce
nouveau groupe moi je suis assez
d'accord avec ce que disait arnaud
benedetti à l'instant à savoir que ça va
plutôt renforcer le rôle du modem et
dans une moindre mesure du groupe du
groupe agir mais ça remet en quelque
sorte françois bayrou au centre du jeu
parce que la promesse première du
maquereau nisme était ce positionnement
central est finalement françois bayrou
avait été obligé de reconnaître que même
macron lui avait volé le mistigri en
quelque sorte
eh ben c'est lui que ça va remettre plus
en situation de peser sur les décisions
du gouvernement parce que si on regarde
le groupe en question
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait de véritable
demande dans l'opinion correspondant à
ce qu'il se propose d'incarner d'autant
que c'est un groupe finalement assez
disparate c'est plus des gens qui sont
dans le mécontentement vis-à-vis pas
forcément d'ailleurs que la politique
mais aussi du fonctionnement du groupe à
l'assemblée à l'assemblée nationale
parce que je crois que cette question là
est assez importante la manière dont
gilo gens notamment a pu piloter ce
groupe n'a pas toujours été bien perçue
par un certain nombre de députés
je crois que ces gens là et on l'a vu
notamment avec la candidature de cédric
villani à paris ne sont pas forcément
des gens ces terres qui surf sur des
thématiques qui peuvent être populaire
dans une certaine partie de l'opinion
mais qui ne se traduisent pas
nécessairement mécaniquement par des
voix dans les urnes dont je pense que de
ce point de vue là et notamment parce
qu'il ya une échéance importante qui va
arriver avec le vote du budget 2009 21
il va falloir vraiment prendre des
décisions sérieuses je pense que le
modem sera plus en situation de peser
que le groupe en question a nommé des
tic vous n'y voyez pas une fragilisation
des manuels mettront il ya déjà eu une
quinzaine de départs successifs depuis
le début de la législature aujourd'hui
aurélien tâche et claque la porte
aussi la fondation de ce groupe avec des
anciens marcheurs à ce que ce n'est pas
justement la fin de l' eldorado
on a vu au début ces marcheurs plein
d'enthousiasmé qui finalement s'effrite
au fil du temps et du catena oui alors
si vous voulez sur le plan de la
mythologie de la macro ni c'est la fin
son ombre de cet eldorado comme vous
l'avez vu qui permettait de rassembler
la droite et la gauche sur le fond la
sociologie aujourd'hui électorale du
maquereau nisme c'est une sociologie qui
a plutôt dériver vers le sample droit
donc en l'occurrence eu cette dérive
vers le centre droit du maquereau nisme
elle et elle correspond à l'état en tous
cas d'une partie de l'opinion publique
donc si cette fragilité parlementaire
peut apparaître en effet comme un
handicap
facialement pour cette majorité sur le
fond aujourd'hui clairement il ne s'agit
pas vraisemblablement de 10 ans d'un
obstacle insurmontable pour l'exécutif
s'est en effet quelque part en matière
d'image quelque chose qui peut
apparaître tout d'un coup comme une
ligne de fracture qui s'installerait à
l'intérieur de l'âme acronymes et la
macro n'y a depuis le début finalement
du monde à assumer globalement c'est
azur lamento vers le centre droit qui
lui a d'ailleurs plutôt réussi aux
dernières élections européennes donc en
l'occurrence c'est plus se disent on a
un problème d'image est pour l'instant
qu'un problème de fond politique et de
fonctionnement
jean sébastien ferjou on a tous en
mémoire ces frondeurs de l'ale gauche il
n'y a pas si longtemps autour d'un
certain françois hollande salue avait
pas franchement porté chance vous n'avez
voyez pas du tout de comparaison vous
mais probablement emmanuel macron
sera-t-il capable de tirer les leçons
justement de ce qui est arrivé à
françois hollande c'est à dire que
vraisemblablement on a accordé beaucoup
trop d'importance
en tout cas les responsables de la
majorité socialiste à l'époque ont
accordé beaucoup trop d'importance à ces
frondeurs qui n'avait à vrai dire même
pas d'unité véritable entre eux c'était
une espèce de création médiatique ou ou
de créature médiatique alors ça
permettait aux frondeurs en question
d'avoir plus de surface parce que
forcément quand on est porteur d'une
parole suivante la demande médiatique
est parfois plus forte mais je pense que
françois hollande a surestimé leur
pouvoir de nuisance et que s'il n'avait
pas écouté les frondeurs
il ne s'en serait que mieux porter quand
vous regardez les résultats électoraux
les frondeurs en question ont quasiment
tous été balayés lors des dernières
législatives ce qui montre bien que même
à gauche
en tout cas sur un électorat peut-être
un peu plus à gauche il n'y avait pas de
demande pour ces frondeurs là donc je
pense que là la question elle va être
sensiblement la même pour les gens qui
sont dans ce groupe en revanche ça pose
quand même une difficulté alors pas
politique je suis d'accord avec ce que
disait renommée des benedetti mais
peut-être peut-être plus une difficulté
d'image c'est à dire j'ai cru comprendre
qu'elle macron était en quête de
radicalité pour se réinventer pour la
deuxième moitié de son quinquennat c'est
plus difficile de revendiquer une
radicalité notamment une radicalité
peut-être sur le terrain de
l'environnement
si vous avez un matthieu orphelin qui
est un des députés proches de nicolas
hulot qui devrait avoir vocation à être
dans ce groupe aux côtés de delphine
batho ancien ministre de l'ecologie
socialiste bref ce sera plus difficile
de revendiquer cette radicalité si vous
avez à côté un groupe qui ne cesse de
répéter oui mais regardez il ya que des
mots il n'y a pas de réalisation j'ai
justement je puisse venir sur mathieu
leurs fans à mano benedetti cet
écologiste on rappelle proche de nicolas
hulot s'est dit quelque chose justement
que 28e enfin la claque la porte a dit
quelque chose du bilan écologique du
gouvernement mais cran selon vous ça dit
tout simplement que le packaging qui
était le packaging qui avait voulu
mettre en place emmanuel macron avec une
touche verte et cette prise de guerre
que constitue et nicolas hulot
aujourd'hui nos perd plus et ne
fonctionne plus mais vous savez il y à
un grand nombre de chrome est ce qui
était portée par emmanuel macron et sa
majorité qui ont disparu au fur et à
mesure du déroulement du monde à on peut
considérer que d'ailleurs la promesse
écologique
à dix on s'est dissoute depuis le départ
de nicolas hulot donc on est je pense
dans l'achèvement d'un processus qui se
traduit par le départ de ces gens qui
étaient de toute façon déjà orienté à
gauche et qui ne se retrouvent
vraisemblablement plus aujourd'hui dans
le logiciel politique et surtout dans la
pratique plutôt politique
deux des manuels macron et de l'exécutif
et de la gestion également je rejoins
jean bastien jean sébastien ferjou la
gestion du groupe parlementaire et donc
on est là disons avec une séquence qui
est en train de se clore mais qui encore
une fois ne constitue pas
vraisemblablement une rupture aussi
fondamental qu'on peut l'imaginer dans
le fonctionnement de la de la majorité
le nom que cette majorité ne va pas au
devant de gros problèmes et de grosses
difficultés
mais ce n'est vraisemblablement sa part
la constitution de ce groupe
parlementaire qui aujourd'hui doit être
considérée comme disons une étape loin
tournant dans le monde à des manuels
macro il n'empêche
vous avez l'air de ne pas y voir une
grande menace mais enfin c'est quand
même assez critique hier du côté du
gouvernement sig et ndèye la
porte-parole évoquait un contresens
politique jean sébastien ferjou c'est
une critique de bon sens ou de mauvaise
foi non je pense qu incontestablement
c'est une espèce de rupture avec la
première l'initiale du mak remis ça
montre bien que la promesse du
dépassement du dépassement du clivage
gauche droite elle n'a pas eu lieu
donc je comprends que parce que le mot
de dépassement est vraiment celui qui a
employé les responsables de la majorité
pour disqualifier un peu ce groupe en
disant que c'était des gens qui
n'assument pas leurs responsabilités et
qui n'assumait pas le mandat finalement
sur lequel il avait été vu puisque là
d'un programme en particulier il y avait
sa promesse du dépassement des clivages
habituels
donc moi je suis entièrement d'accord
avec ce que disait arnaud b des litiges
je pense que le sujet pourrait même à
chrome pour la majorité il est dans
l'opinion il est dans la défiance on
nous voit dans l'opinion on a vu ces
derniers jours quelques images du
présent la république confronté de
vraies paroles de défiance notamment des
soignants disons mais quoi qu'il annonce
finalement il a de la peine à convaincre
les français que les actions vont suivre
les paroles
la création de ce groupe là
politiquement elle n'a pas grande grande
importance en revanche l acte quand même
le fait que la promesse initiale du
maquereau nice elle s'est un peu
évaporée et que le président est en
quête de réinvention en quelque sorte
d'un adn
politique à la fois pour la fin de ce
quinquennat et pour une éventuelle
candidature en 2022 parce qu'il ne
pourra plus refaire le coup en quelque
sorte qui lui a réussi du dépassement du
simple déplacement du clivage gauche
droite ça ça ne sera plus possible
maintenant
merci à tous dès 2h novelli betty
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire jean sébastien ferjou
fondateur du site atlantico merci à tous
les deux elle reste avec nous donc
quelques instants nous parlerons du plan
de relance annoncé en europe par
emmanuel macron et un gala merkel à
hauteur de 500 milliards d'euros face à
l'impact économique du comité 19 puis
nous reviendrons sur la réponse de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé face
à la pandémie
alors que la chine et des états unis
multiplient les passes d'armes
[Musique]
l'afrique qui compte 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple les roms pour les
états unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus on a proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif et
concernait seulement des personnes âgées
à haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population ça l'est
beaucoup plus facilement puisqu'elle
venait de sortir d'une d'une épidémie à
ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
que si on aura affaire à deux épidémies
aussi dangereuse qui est des mollahs et
coronavirus ça pourrait être très très
difficile pour nous
[Musique]
et
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on sait combien d'enfants sont
victimes de ces violences et qui sont
concernés par ces drames qui se déroule
dans le huis clos familial pendant la
période actuelle il est difficile de
dire précisément combien d'enfants sont
concernés car en fait on a très peu de
visibilité
nous savons simplement que il y à des
situations effectivement qui s'aggrave
dans les familles il ya toutes les
classes sociales qui sont concernés par
la maltraitance il faut qu'on le lise
ils redisent là le problème c'est que
dans le cas du confinement il n'y a plus
cet entourage et tout se fait à distance
ce qui fait qu'il est très difficile de
repérer par téléphone par visiophone ces
situations et notre inquiétude un porte
plutôt sur ce que nous voyons pas la
partie immergée de l'iceberg en fait
parce que les très difficile pour les
enfants malgré tout d'après eux mêmes et
dans ce cas là on n'entend rien ça se
fait totalement dans le silence
[Musique]
21h30 merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
rt france
le couple franco-allemand au chevet de
l'europe emmanuel macron et angela
merkel se sont entretenus par
visioconférence cet après midi les deux
dirigeants ont annoncé 500 milliards
d'euros deux plans de relance en europe
il s'agit de faire face aux
répercussions économiques de la pandémie
les deux dirigeantes appelé les pays
membres à faire preuve de solidarité
l'europe il faut bien le dire et avoir
cette lucidité a été sans doute mise en
défaut au début de cette crise d'abord
parce que la compétence sanitaire n'est
pas une compétence communautaire et donc
nous ne devons pas demander à l'union
européenne ce qui n'est pas de sa
compétence
aussi parce qu'il ya eu des réflexes
nationalistes en particulier sur la
gestion des frontières y compris à
l'intérieur de l'espace schengen et nous
devons à cet égard tirer toutes les
leçons de cette pandémie
nous devons aussi dire que des actions
remarquables au niveau européen ont été
conduites
l'europe doit être solidaire c'est
pourquoi il s'agit d'avoir une reprise
économique rapide et c'est pourquoi nous
voulons mettre en place un fonds
temporaire de 500 milliards d'euros
des lieux devrait fournir des dépenses
budgétaires c'est à dire non pas des
prêts mais des dépenses budgétaires pour
les secteurs et les régions les plus
touchées
et pour la partie analyse nous sommes en
direct avec l'autre blanchemaison expert
en relations internationales bonsoir
claude blanchemaison merci d'être beau
est-ce que l'on peut parler de grandes
décisions aujourd'hui que peut-on
retenir
ah oui je crois que c'est une grande
nation d'abord parce que tout le monde
reprocher l'union européenne d'être
immobile de regarder passer les trains
et là tout d'un coup le l'union
européenne si la proposition
franco-allemande est acceptée va
accroître sa force de frappe de 500
milliards d'euros pour les années 2000
et 2022 et puis le budget de l'union
européenne est plafonnée à environ 1% du
pnb l'état membre et l'allemagne tenait
beaucoup à cette limite et ne voulait
pas que cette limite soit dépassé alors
comment est on arrivé d'où sortent ces
500 milliards de d'euros
eh bien l'astuce consiste tout
simplement à autoriser ce qu'on
interdise auparavant c'est-à-dire a
autorisé la commission à emprunter sur
les marchés financiers les états en pâte
se fortement du trésor les entreprises
empruntent avec les obligations pour les
grandes entreprises et la commission qui
a un budget de près de 170 millions
milliards d'euros par an n'avaient pas
droit d'emprunter
eh bien on vient de l'autoriser si
encore une fois la proposition
franco-allemande est suivie on vient de
d'imaginer qu'elle pourra emprunter et
évidemment elle n'aura aucun mal à
emprunter sur les marchés financiers
donc je crois que c'est une importante
innovation et que la chancelière a fait
preuve d'un grand sens politique ans en
allant contre une partie de son
entourage qui finalement ne souhaitait
pas aller dans ce sens alors puisqu'il
s'agit d'un emprunt il faudra bien le
rembourser eh bien d'abord comment sera
dépensé cet argent il sera il sera
ajouté au budget communautaire et la
commission utilisera ce fonds de relance
pour faire des notations aux entreprises
au secteur aux régions qui ont été le
plus affectés par la crise tout le
remboursement
eh bien ce sont les états membres qui se
substitueront bénéficiaires des prêts
pour rembourser avec un échéancier qui
reste à négocier avec aussi des
conditions et des pourcentages qui reste
encore une fois à négocier entre les
états membres
alors je crois que tout ça va se mettre
en place et par ailleurs comme l'a dit
le président français à qu'en dehors de
ce fonds de relance
les deux dirigeants se sont mis d'accord
pour
faire ce qui peut être fait dans le
cadre des traités en matière de santé
les traités prévoient que la santé ce
sont les états mais on peut sûrement
faire des stocks de précaution
on peut sûrement travailler et financer
la recherche sur les vaccins sur les
traitements
on peut faire en sorte que une agence de
santé surveille l'état de santé l'état
sanitaire des divers états membres et
ceci a été accepté
ainsi d'ailleurs que la recherche d'une
politique de souveraineté industrielle
avec un système de surveillance des
investissements étrangers
ceux ci avaient déjà commencé par dans
le peu d'enjeu dans un passé récent mais
ceci va être développé c'est donc une
décision franco-allemande qui est très
importante maintenant évidemment reste à
transposer au niveau des 27 est
justement club blanchemaison c'est la
question tout le monde se pose comment
cette proposition d' emmanuel macron et
d'angela merkel va pouvoir se
concrétiser
bah comme vous savez je suis plutôt
optimiste donc je pense que on va
pouvoir y arriver parce que d'abord au
cours des semaines précédentes beaucoup
de contacts ont été pris bien sûr avec
la commission avec reçues la fonera yen
qui est très associée à ces travaux lui
aussi avec un certain nombre d'états
membres et que d'ailleurs l'idée de
recourir à l'emprunt était une idée qui
avait fait son chemin au cours des
derniers mois les choses ont beaucoup
changé avec la crise du corps ogg et du
coronavirus est je pense que les états
sont prêts maintenant aller dans ce sens
bien sûr les italiens environ 500
millions c'est pas assez il faudrait que
ce soit le double 500 milliards
pardon il faudrait que ça soit 1000
milliards et puis probablement les
néerlandais vont regarder dans le détail
pour vérifier que ceux-ci ne revient pas
par un détour de raisonnement un petit
peu compliqué à mutualiser la tête
puisque ça c'est le point de rupture
qu'on fixe et les néerlandais
ils ne veulent pas de mutualisation de
la laine
mais évidemment en fonction des clés de
remboursement que l'on définira entre et
amant il pourra y avoir une partie en
réalité de mutualisation de des
subventions qui ont été versés aux
entreprises au secteur ou aux régions
particulièrement touchées par la crise
alors et la commission doit faire une
proposition en bonne et due forme à la
fin du mois en principe le vin le je
crois que c'est le 27 mai est
effectivement ensuite les états membres
discuteront de cette proposition est sur
cette base cyr ont trouvé un compromis
avec naturellement les bons offices du
président du conseil européen je relève
aussi qu'à partir du 1er juillet c'est
l'allemagne qui exerce la présidence des
conseils des ministres
donc le conseil des mythes et finance
est propre que l'allemagne aura à coeur
de mener ce projet à bien et on peut
penser que le parlement européen sera
aussi favorable puisqu'il souhaitait que
les moyens financiers de l'union
européenne souhaite accrue
certains états membres vont sans doute
aussi besoin d'une ratification par
leurs parlements craie blanche saison
dernière question quelles seront les
implications politiques de ces décisions
en europe
ben je crois que les applications sont
importantes puisque en effet c'est un
petit peu ce soir
une résurrection de la capacité à faire
des propositions et effectivement ça
passe par le tandem franco allemand un
travail assez important a été arrêté
fait au cours des dernières semaines
et comme je le disais tout à l'heure nos
partenaires sont déjà au courant alors
il reste en effet pas mal de discussions
à conduire mais ce sera surtout sur la
base des propositions de la de la
commission je pense aussi qu'il est
important
finalement quelques quelques jours après
la décision de la
cour constitutionnelle de karlsruhe que
la présidence allemande que la
présidente al que là que la chancelière
allemand s'engage dans cette voie
bien sûr elle ne peut pas contredire
ouvertement de front la cour
constitutionnelle qui était un organe
très important en allemagne mais elle
montre que elle est prête à à s'engager
politiquement avec son gouvernement à
fond pour sauver l'europe et sauver la
zone euro
donc ça je crois que c'est très
important à un moment où dans quelques
diverses parties du monde mais aussi à
l'intérieur de l'europe
on pense que l'europe est en mauvaise
posture merci claude blanche maison pour
votre analyse complète de la situation
après donc ces annonces des manuels
macro et d'un gué la merkel et à
l'instant une réaction celle de
christine lagarde la patronne du fmi
les propositions franco allemandes sont
pour l ambitieux ciblée est bien venu
trouver une réponse commune face aux
coronavirus c'était donc l'objectif
cet après midi à l'assemblée annuelle de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
visioconférence a réuni les
représentants des 194 pays membres de
cette agence onusienne sur fond de
tensions persistantes
washington rejette vous le savez un sur
la chine et l' oms la responsabilité de
la crise qui frappe les états unis alors
que faut-il retenir de cette journée les
détails avec le cas tu as une conférence
sous tension dès les premières minutes
le secrétaire général de l'onu donne le
ton
nous avons entendu beaucoup de messages
de solidarité mais nous n'avons pas vu
beaucoup d'unités dans notre réponse au
kovy 19
certains pays ont adopté des stratégies
différentes parfois contradictoires et
aujourd'hui le monde entier en paye le
prix fort
une introduction salé à destination des
pays qui n'ont pas respecté les
recommandations de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé dans le viseur
d'antonio goûter res notamment les états
unis
si washington s'en prend régulièrement à
l'onu depuis des années c'est maintenant
son institution en charge de la santé
qui cristallise sa colère donald trump
accuse le ms de n'être que le
porte-parole de pékin dans cette crise
sanitaire
résultat le mois dernier en pleine
pandémie
le président américain a suspendu la
contribution financière américaine à
l'om est ce la privant ainsi de 15% de
son budget total la chine déclenche
aussi les foudres de la maison blanche
elle est accusée de très mauvaise
gestion et de dissimulation de la
propagation du virus
une allégation démentie une nouvelle
fois cet après midi par le président
chinois aux hommes we have a great tout
au long des événements nous avons agi
dans un esprit d'ouverture de façon
transparente et responsable
nous avons fourni des informations à
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
aux pays concernés en temps et en heure
nous avons communiqué la séquence du
génome du virus le plus rapidement
possible nous avons partagé sans réserve
de notre expérience et notre savoir
médical avec le monde entier
nous avons fait tout ce qui était en
notre pouvoir pour aider les pays en
difficulté la chine va donner 2
milliards de dollars américains sur une
période de deux ans pour lutter contre
le coronavirus si un vaccin chinois
contre le coc vie 19 est découvert il
sera considéré comme un bien public
mondial
un bien public mondial c'est aussi
l'idée défendue par la france
au milieu de cette crise sanitaire paris
tente de jouer les médiateurs et appelle
en finir avec les tensions diplomatiques
au moment où les soignants du monde
entier se bat avec bravoure contre le
coronavirus ne pouvons pas nous
permettre d'être divisés nous n'avons
pas le droit de fuir nos responsabilités
nous devons au contraire d assumer
collectivement pour être efficace nous
avons ici l'opportunité de lutter d'une
seule voix contre l'épidémie
sans complaisance mais aussi sans
accusation a fondé nous devons être unis
exigent est clair c'est notre devoir
le texte présenté aujourd'hui aux 194
pays membres demandent la mise en place
d'un processus d'évaluation pour
examiner
la pertinence des mesures sanitaires
recommandé par l'om est ce au cours des
derniers mois sera-t-il adopter ou non
réponse attendue à genève ce mardi alors
concrètement qu'a réalisé l'om est
depuis le début de la crise éléments de
réponse en images
[Musique]
oh
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis et ses terres au royaume uni avec
bharat par camilla expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir baratin gagna merci d'être avec
nous en direct pour vu de l'extérieur ce
soir l'om est-ce pointé du doigt dans
cette fille notamment par donald trump
est ce qu'il ya des fautes commises
selon vous en tant que spécialiste par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé est
ce qu'il faudrait qu'elle revoie son
fonctionnement
il faut être très prudent
le ténor ems est la seule institution
qui surveille la santé le bien-être de
beaucoup d'états membres et la confiance
en le ms est nécessaire le ms doit être
soutenue doit être en pleine confiance
peut être capable d'effectuer son
travail notamment dans les pays plus
pauvres les pays pauvres ont besoin de
l'om est bien plus que les pays riches
les pays occidentaux nous avons donc
besoin de la soutenir
et bien sûr il est très important de
tirer des enseignements de nos loudes
batteur action il faut voir comment
améliorer la situation et comment mieux
soutenir l'om est ce pour vous un
l'organisation mondiale de la santé à
gérer parfaitement cette crise il n'y a
rien à redire selon vous seul le temps
nous le dira le ms et une organisation
très large et des personnes et me donne
moi annonçait que cette crise apparaît
très bien avant l'organisation gelé
qualifiée de pandémie au moins deux
semaines avant l'om est ce donc
vous le voyez le ms est bien plus lente
dans sa réaction
mais il faut également savoir que le ms
ne peut faire son travail aussi bien que
les états membres laisse le faire le
problème un que msc que les états
membres protègent leurs positions
respectives
nous perdons donc au niveau de la
science il ya un peu plus de politique
dans les rouages de l'om embodied des
états membres défendent leurs intérêts
leur posture il serait mieux que des
experts des états membres qui ne serait
pas parcieux envers ses états membres
j'espère que je suis claire oui vous
êtes parfaitement clair et c'est
intéressant comme point de vue parce que
justement l'une des principales
critiques de donald trump c'est la
complaisance entre guillemets de l' oms
vis-à-vis notamment de la chine
est ce que vous vous êtes d'accord avec
ce postulat où vous ne partagez pas du
tout ce diagnostic
je ne pense pas cela je suis extrêmement
neutre
ce n'est pas une question de
complaisance envers quiconque
le ms je peux faire son travail et que
si la chine la forme de ces problèmes
donc jusqu'à ce que la chine est dit
elle mais ce qu'un nouveau problème
était apparu alors le travail ne peut
pas commencer
c'est une organisation de santé mondiale
il ya beaucoup de commissions de comités
et la prise de décision est plus lente
de ce fait je souhaiterais que nous
redéfinissions la façon dont les comités
scientifiques sont gérées afin que les
décisions se fasse bien pu rapidement
afin de limiter les débats et la
consultation qui font perdre du temps à
noter bien sûr glow ms doit être financé
correctement
afin d'avoir tu aimais bureaux
compétents sur le terrain alors il ya
une critique qui nous vient du
secrétaire général de l'onu dont dépend
d'ailleurs l'om est ce nous avons vu des
expressions solidarité mais très peu
d'unités dans notre réponse face à la
coved 19 les pays ont suivi des
stratégies différentes parfois
contradictoires et nous en payons tous
le prix fort voici la déclaration
d'antonio guterres est ce aujourd'hui
est-ce que iyad ça justement on ne paye
le prix fort dans cette gestion de
lakovic 19 par manque d'unité des pays
membres justement nous avons un des
différences d'opinion il niveau de la
gestion de l'épidémie
les coréens du sud ont fait du très bon
travail ils l ont testé les contacte
alors que les etats-unis ont fait tout à
fait le contraire
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas un problème
pour les états unis et n'ont pas
accompli ce qu'il aurait dû faire à
temps elle même qui bénéficiait d'
avertissement très clair donc appelé les
pays asiatiques les chinois les coréens
les taiwan et les habitants de singapour
ont fait du très bon travail très
rapidement les européens l'italie en
tout cas a été prise de court et les
américains on est tout simplement décidé
qu'il ne fallait pas s'en soucier
effectivement nous avons besoin d'une
santé publique internationale qui
travaille dans l'unité qui décide d'un
plan sinon effectivement ce genre de
catastrophe se reproduira vous évoquez
nécessaire soutien financier l oms or il
se trouve que les etats-unis ont annoncé
vouloir arrêter de subventionner
l'organisation pour vous ça va avoir de
conséquences très graves des
conséquences très graves
c'est déplorable et d'une pandémie la
pierre que la planète est connue les
états unis décident pour une raison
quelconque c'est inexplicable d'arrêter
de financer l'om s c'est une leçon très
importante en tant que communauté
mondiale nous devons travailler de
concert nous devons permettra aucun pays
qu'il s'agisse de la chine de l'union
européenne des etats unis ou des pays
d'amérique du sud
dicté le comportement et le financement
de l oms et d'un entre deux jambes
s'il n'y a plus de financement le
travail est impossible le ms ne peut pas
mener son travail dans les pays les plus
pauvres à et donc la circulation du
virus en afrique reviendra sur le devant
de la scène et aura un impact sur les
pays européens et dans le reste du monde
donc il serait dans l'intérêt des états
unis de l'union européenne du japon et
de la chine deux continuer à financer le
ms afin de limiter le nombre des cas
dans le monde entier
c'est dans leur propre intérêt
ma dernière question aujourd'hui lors de
l'assemblée annuelle 1 de l'om est ce la
chine s'est dite favorable à une enquête
sur l'origine de l'épidémie une fois
qu'elle sera enrayée on sait on rappelle
que donald trump accusent la chine
justement d'être à l'origine de cette
épidémie de l'avoir caché vous pensez
qu'on aura un jour là la vérité sur ce
qui s'est vraiment passé et notamment
sur la façon dont la chine a géré la
crise du corps d'un virus c'est un sujet
très important et il y a deux parties
comment la chine a géré la crise
et l'origine des nouveaux virus c'est ce
que j'appelle la prévention on peut
dépenser des millions afin d'arrêter
l'apparition de nouveaux virus en
changeant de pratiks humaine beaucoup de
pratiques humaines par exemple celle de
chasser ou de capturer des animaux
sauvages de ce 200 nourrir ou alors de
donner des antibiotiques à des animaux
qu'ils engraissent plus rapidement et
pour accroître les profits sont des
problèmes causés par l'humanité qui
existent dans le monde entier notamment
aux états unis
il faut mettre un terme à des
comportements nuisibles comme cela sinon
on passera des milliers de milliers de
milliards après l'étape de la prévention
merci bar à tapas le kenya expert en
maladies infectieuses à l'université
d'exeter d'avoir été avec nous pour vu
de l'extérieur ce soir donc dans le
reste de l'actualité cet attentat à la
voiture piégée en afghanistan au moins
neuf morts et une quarantaine de blessés
selon les autorités
un véhicule militaire qui visait un
bâtiment des services de renseignements
afghans selon les autorités locales
toutes les victimes en ferait partie des
talibans ont revendiqué l'attentât selon
l'un de leurs porte paroles comme une
réponse à la déclaration de guerre par
l'ennemi et un attentat qui intervient
au lendemain d'un accord de partage du
pouvoir entre le président ashraf ghani
son rival abdullah abdullah tous les
deux revendiqué la victoire à l'élection
présidentielle de septembre dernier
clément hospital
c'est un nouvel accord historique
cette cérémonie de signature entre le
président afghan ashraf ghani et son
rival abdullah abdullah
met fin à plusieurs mois de conflits qui
ont plongé l'afghanistan dans une crise
politique
un nouvel espoir pour essayer de mettre
fin à plus de 40 ans de guerre est un
racisme
aujourd'hui est un grand jour historique
pour notre bien aimée afghanistan les
afghans ont prouvé qu'ils
réfléchissaient sagement et
collectivement à leur intérêt national
ils ont trouvé leur unité par les
dirigeants ici présents ont fait
beaucoup d'efforts ils sont un
encouragement pour la population afghane
il y a aucun doute sur le fait que la
communauté internationale soutient cet
accord politique tout comme les pays de
la région tâche serait plus pareil même
kaka en nommant abdullah la tête du
conseil de paix qui va conduire les
pourparlers avec les talibans
l'accord fait renaître l'espoir d'une
avancée au sujet de l'entente conclue
entre les états unis et les insurgés qui
ouvrait la voie au retrait des soldats
américains
si les opposants armés renoncer à la
violence et si des pourparlers s'ouvrait
avec kaboul cette nouvelle alliance
conclue ce dimanche a donc été saluée
par washington et la communauté
internationale heureux d'apprendre
qu'achraf ghani et abdullah abdullah ont
conclu un accord pour une gouvernance
inclusive
nous nous félicitons de leur engagement
à agir maintenant pour la paix en
afghanistan
je salue la décision des dirigeants
politiques de l'afghanistan de mettre un
terme à leurs différends et d'unir leurs
efforts pour former un gouvernement
inclusif
l'otan reste déterminée à aider
l'afghanistan à instaurer une paix
durable
le pays connaît une recrudescence des
violences dont une attaque contre une
maternité de kaboul la semaine dernière
qui a fait 24 morts dont plusieurs
nourrissons
un autre défi auquel le pays doit
également faire face la propagation
rapide du corona virus dans la
population c'est la fin de cette
émission au prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans quelques minutes rester
avec
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on voit pas ailleurs
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
[Musique]
depuis le début de cette crise les
français sont dans le flou avec des
informations contradictoires
quelles en sont les conséquences
psychologiquement la peur quand même
socio économique c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même une détresse socio économique
très très fortes notamment pour pour les
actifs bien évidemment plus vous êtes
âgé plus vous avez peur du réel de la
mort c'est évident les études elle
montre que oui pourquoi 30 à 40%
il y à un stress modéré il ya un stress
sévère pour à peu près 5%
on a un focus assez fort sur les
adolescents étonnamment un focus sur les
aînés également très important c'est à
dire que ceux qui résisteront le mieux
ce sont entre guillemets la classe d
actifs
est ce que ce nom vous l'être humain
peut gérer une proximité quotidienne
avec sa famille comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça resserre les
liens vous contraire à ce que ça les
haltères veut nous devons réapprendre le
goût du comportement collectif voilà le
goût un peu d' une autodiscipline le
goût du civisme parce que si nous vivons
ça simplement comme une restriction de
nos libertés individuelles comme si nous
ne vivons pas ça comme une aventure
collective de protection solidaire des
ans a été jeune
ça va être la extraordinairement
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les poussons terme la stratégie de
conquête de marchés à l'exportation
s'appuie sur une politique offensive de
pillage de fleurons du secteur
stratégique
le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
en jouant sur quatre critères qu'est
l'argent l'idéologie légaux et la
compromission
ce phénomène il est mondial on le
retrouve pas
c'est pourquoi on est frappé par la
naïveté des personnels et d'encadrement
un seul ce type de pratique une existe
sur la planète
beaucoup d'acteurs tchéquie et sans
aucune hésitation ni morale la fin
justifie les moyens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doit selon vont jouer
à lévis mais quel rôle joue-t-elle dans
les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils étaient pas préparés
mais les villes elles se sont connectés
tout de suite entre elles pour voir
comment elles pouvaient coopérer il ya
eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des masques
des matériels médicaux d'une commune à
l'autre selon vous à quoi pouvons
rassembler les îles comment est ce qu
elle pour transformer après la pandémie
la crise maintenant à fait bien
comprendre qu'on peut pas s'oublier des
banlieues on peut pas oublier les
quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement ils font partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte
elle n'est pas seulement d'elle-même
elle parle aussi de comment créer cette
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
l'hôpital en première ligne dans les
lignes du coronavirus le secteur attend
beaucoup des négociations qui débutent
le 25 mai avec le gouvernement pour un
ségur de la santé une promesse faite par
emmanuel macron au plus fort de
l'épidémie coronavirus 35 heures
augmentation des salaires après les
annonces l'hôpital attend des actes
concrets après le retour en classe
d'écoliers 185 mille élèves des collèges
de zones vertes ont fait leur rentrée en
se pliant à un strict protocole
sanitaire dans le port obligatoire du
masque après un premier week end est
confiné la prudence est plus que jamais
de mise avec l'apparition de 25 nouveaux
foyers infectieux depuis
confinement un fonds de solidarité
européen de 500 milliards d'euros voilà
l'initiative germano française emmanuel
macron yang et la merkel ont fait
l'annoncé cet après-midi objectif
investir dans la protection sanitaire et
la transition écologique avec en toile
de fond la souveraineté économique
conséquence le dax et le cac 40 clôture
en hausse ce soir
la chine s'est dit favorable à une
enquête sur l'origine de l'épidémie une
fois qu'elle sera enrayée
une déclaration du leader chinois xi
jingping à l'occasion de l'assemblée
annuelle de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé une réunion sous tension les
etats-unis accusent pékin d'être
responsable de la
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france il est
22 heures heure française
le personnel hospitalier temps des
réponses concrètes de la part du
gouvernement
malgré les annonces d'olivier et veyran
ce week end et la volonté du
gouvernement d'instaurer un c ur de la
santé les syndicats des milieux
hospitaliers maintiennent la menace
d'une mobilisation le 16 juin à créteil
aujourd'hui des dizaines de soignants
ont manifesté leur mécontentement
on a vécu des moments hyper difficile
pendant la période covic là ça va un peu
mieux mais on a on a manqué de matériel
où nous a envoyé des renforts des gens
qui étaient peu formés
donc ça a été très très difficile
pendant un moment et là aujourd'hui
montre qu'on est mécontent de ce qui
s'est passé et que si on avait eu plus
de l'île de ré à ça serait sans doute
mieux passer comme en allemagne
voilà c'est l'heure des comptes et c'est
l'heure de relancer nos revendications
il y aura peut-être des prochainement d
les mobilisations nous nos
revendications n'ont pas changé c'est
une augmentation salariale que nous
promet une belle macro et on attend de
voir c'est d'abord cerner tout le monde
c'est à dire tous les professionnels pas
que les soignants à l'hôpital également
des administratifs et des services
techniques sont très souvent oublié on
veut également des embauches on
travaille en sous effectif depuis trop
d'années et on veut des budgets
hospitaliers à la hauteur des besoins de
la population puisque on supprime depuis
des années des lieux de vie et qu'on
n'arrive plus à répondre aux besoins de
la population
on a des personnels qui sont épuisés
physiquement épuisés psychologie font
des heures sup initialement devait être
payé presque gracieusement et grassement
finalement il ya du retard on sait même
pas si on va les avoir les primes que
tout le monde devait toucher pareil
c'est fiasco enfin voilà on va sur des
promesses que personne ne tient enfin
son gouvernement ne tient pas et tant
l'impression qu'ils donnent à chaque
jour qui évolue on est prêts ce qui m a
faussement sur une jambe de bois tu es
fabrice di vizio avocats spécialistes
dans la défense des professionnels de
santé dans le collectif de médecins ces
19 a porté plainte contre edouard
philippe et agnès buzyn elle dénonce un
décalage entre les annonces du
gouvernement et les actions apportées
le problème c'est que on a bien vu dans
cette crise que la parole du
gouvernement étudie parole donc il faut
quand même cruellement se méfier c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui
alors laquelle je vous parle alors que
la crise n'est pas finie certains
membres du personnel hospitalier dont
toujours pas de masques ffp2 c'est à
dire que vous prenez le bloc opératoire
qui va reprendre les infirmiers de bloc
n'ont pas de masques ffp2 tous qui a
décalage comme d'habitude entre le
discours du gouvernement et les actions
du gouvernement ce qu'ont cherché à
rassurer les soignants mais elle est
rassurée avec des paroles avaient reçu
avec des discours et on peut
légitimement comprendre que ces derniers
on est assez on fait des discours et
demande maintenant à ce qu'on passe à
l'action
et ça je pense que c'est vraiment le mot
d'ordre est après le premier bol d'air
d'un week end est confiné jour de
rentrée des classes pour les collégiens
de 6e et 5e en zone verte 185 mille
élèves au total 2
rentrée après celle des maternelles et
des primaires lundi dernier on a appris
ce matin 70 99 avait été détecté dans
les écoles depuis le début du
confinement
le ministre de l'éducation nationale on
a fait l'annoncé il était en visite ce
matin dans l'eure à l'occasion de la
réouverture d'un collège il ya plus de
quarante mille écoles qui ont ouvert en
france sur sur cinquante mille et nous
en a 70 qui ont fermé depuis la semaine
dernière c'est donc un pourcentage très
faible et il faut savoir que c'est dans
une même ville par souvent parlant de si
vous prenez la ville de sens 25 des 70
dont je vous parle sont dans la même
ville parce qu'il ya eu un cas de co
vide dans cette ville donc il y a si
vous voulez la nécessité d'être stricte
rigoureux et donc le fait qu'on soit
parfois amené à faire une école ne doit
pas inquiéter ça fait partie au
contraire du fait que dès qu'on a une
suspicion mais on est attentif parce que
ça ferme et puis éventuellement sa ré
ouvre une fois que les choses sont
claires une rentrée dans le respect des
protocoles sanitaires comme ici au
collège privé saint joseph dans le gers
reportage de hervé grand champ avec
clément hospital il est midi et le self
de ce collège du gers est désertée
l'établissement a rouvert ses portes
récemment et doit s'adapter aux
nouvelles directives pour sa rentrée
pause confinement c'est désormais dans
leur salle de classe que les élèves
prennent leur repas sains par table est
toujours en respectant les distances de
sécurité
c'est un déjeuner en silence presque
studieux chacun groupe à sa classe avec
sa table et c'est il ya marquage sur
chaque espace et chaque place donc il
nous avait dit la fille avec un espace
de cours dédiés et il n'y a aucun
croisement entre les élèves et
les groupes d'élèves et une autre classe
de ce côté-ci sur ce bâtiment avec une
cour de l'autre côté où chaque classe a
son espace est réservé en temps normal
ce collège accueille 300 élèves dont 70
pensionnaires
désormais c'est une quarantaine
d'adolescents qui occupent les lieux
les effectifs des classes ont été
divisées de moitié une table vide ses
parts dès à présent chaque élève de son
voisin une ambiance pesante règne dans
la salle de classe
il est très difficile pour eux de garder
leur masse toute la journée en classe
c'est carrément une torture mais sans
arrêt en train de regarder
ils ont du mal à parler ils ont du mal à
respirer on voit bien que ça l'est ça
les fatigue face est évident et pour
leur permettre de souffler même à
travers leurs masques
le collège a mis en place des cours de
sport quotidien afin que les élèves
puissent se dépenser physiquement en
toute sécurité
la rentrée des élèves de 6e et 5e des
établissements situés en zone verte
s'est effectuée en toute sérénité ce
lundi en ce qui concerne les collégiens
de 4e et de 3e ainsi que les lycéens
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
devrait se prononcer à la fin du mois de
mai et voici maintenant le bilan de
l'épidémie de coronavirus dans
l'hexagone en compte plus de 28 mille
décès selon les chiffres de la direction
générale de la santé
cent trente et une personnes sont mortes
en 24 heures le nombre de personnes en
réanimation continue de baisser et passe
sous la barre des 2000 patients le solde
est négatif comme depuis début avril de
89 malades dans le reste de l'actualité
est présent en france les neiges de la
création d'un neuvième groupe
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale
aura lieu demain lors d'une
vidéoconférence qu'il sera composé de
dissidents de la république en marge
tels que cédric villani ou matthieu
orphelin
les critiques à leur encontre se
multiplient au sein de la majorité et la
pression commence à s'accentuer sur ces
parlementaires les explications en
images
[Musique]
on
bon
[Musique]
on
écoutez présent les analyses d'arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire et de jean
sébastien ferjou fondateur du site
atlantico le gouvernement devra négocier
disons de manière régulière avec
l'ensemble des autres groupes qui
constituent la kz majoritaire le modem
notamment qui voit son poids politique
en l'occurrence augmenté du fait de
cette défection vers la gauche d'un
certain nombre de parlementaires de la
république en marche mais il faut
s'interroger c'est savoir si on est au
début d'un processus de désagrégation
congrès sich de la majorité qui mettrait
en péril même la survie parlementaire de
cette majorité où il s'agirait il d'une
forme de reformatage ou de relookages de
cette majorité avec une aile gauche qui
viendrait d'une certaine manière
redonner une identité
on peut plus à gauche la république en
marche
ça remet en quelque sorte françois
bayrou au centre du jeu parce que la
promesse première du maquereau nisme
était ce positionnement central est
finalement françois bayrou avait été
obligé de reconnaître qu'ils mm macro
lui avait volé le mistigri en quelque
sorte
eh ben c'est lui que ça va remettre plus
en situation de peser sur les décisions
du gouvernement parce que si on regarde
le groupe en question
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait de véritable
demande dans l'opinion correspondant à
ce qu'il se propose d'incarner d'autant
que c'est un groupe finalement assez
disparate c'est plus des gens qui sont
dans le mécontentement vis-à-vis pas
forcément d'ailleurs que la politique
mais aussi du fonctionnement du groupe à
l'assemblée à l'assemblée nationale
parce que je crois que cette question là
est assez important que la manière dont
j le genre notamment a pu piloter ce
groupe n'a pas toujours été bien perçue
par un certain nombre de députés
et toujours en france et violence
argent' et des échauffourées elle est
celui de la mort d'un jeune homme à moto
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche le
parquet de pontoise affirme que les
policiers ne poursuivait pas le jeune
homme mais la famille et les proches de
sabri accusent les forces de l'ordre
présentes sur place d'être en cause dans
l'accident
nicolas winckler avec thomas bonnet se
sont rendus sur place
c'est une famille meurtrie qui nous a
ouvert ses portes
les proches du jeune sabri décédé à
l'âge de 18 ans vivent une peine immense
ils souhaitent comprendre ce qui a pu se
passer ce soir là c'est pas arrivé comme
ça et j'en suis sûr donc voilà je
connais tu qu'est ce qui s'est passé moi
ce que je demande - moi je sais pas
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce que je sais
c'est que j'ai perdu beaucoup à mon fils
lcfc les chefs et les chairs ces
annonces un amour je vais perdre et je
fais confiance à la justice à la loi
voilà j'attends la réponse ne voit là la
mort de ce jeune homme décrit comme
souriant et sans histoires bouleverse
les habitants de ce quartier
d'argenteuil ce qui accentue cette
émotion c'est le flou qui entoure les
circonstances de la mort du jeune homme
les faits se sont déroulés dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche dans un quartier
pavillonnaire de la ville à bord d'une
moto sans casque sabri a perdu la vie au
moment des faits une voiture de la
brigade anticriminalité est présente
près des lieux
mais selon les éléments dévoilés ce
lundi par le parquet de pontoise le
jeune motocycliste n'étaient pas
poursuivis par la voiture de police
présentes à proximité
une version que réfute les proches de
sabri sabri aurait percuté un ce poteau
voiture et
il serait mort à l'hôpital nous on n'y
croit pas du tout on croit pas du tout
certains voisins ont entendu un bruit
par shop
nous on est persuadé que c'est une
bavure et voilà on veut juste que
justice soit faite
dans le quartier où vivait sabri la
colère est forte mais face aux images de
violences qui ont émaillé la commune
d'argenteuil
la famille du jeune homme appelle au
calme et à l'apaisement deux avocates
ont été choisis pour s'occuper du
dossier
une marche en mémoire de sabri aura lieu
mercredi à 15 heures dans la ville
d'argenteuil et pour christophe crépin
un porte parole du syndicat france
police ce drame ne peut pas justifier de
telles violences urbaines
on sait qui circulait avec une moto
cross que il a perdu le contrôle de son
véhicule qui est venu s'encastrer
malheureusement dans un poteau
téléphonique en ciment et suite au choc
il a été transporté à l'hôpital où il
est décédé
je comprends très bien le deuil de cette
famille je comprends très bien il ya
également le fait que ces gens veulent
savoir et c'est normal quand on perd
approche comme ça surtout à un jeune de
18 ans c'est triste mais à rien ne peut
justifier de telles violences urbaines
argenteuil d'ailleurs la famille et nous
mêmes nous ne demandons que toussaint
cesse pendant la période confirme on a
eu beaucoup de mérite urbaine
systématiquement dès qu'il y avait une
petite chose ça partait tout de suite
tout de suite en exactions et des
banlieues entières s'enflammait là
j'espère qu argenteuil vince calmer
parce que rien ne pourra faire ramener
ce jeune homme et moi j'en appelle à une
chose qui est très importante c'est que
systématiquement mes collègues sont
vraiment bénéficié la suspicion de
suspicion et de la présomption de
culpabilité non pas d'innocence
le couple franco-allemand au chevet de
l'europe emmanuel macron et angela
merkel se sont entretenus par
visioconférence cet après midi elle les
deux chefs d'état ont annoncé 500
milliards d'euros deux plans de relance
en europe il s'agit de faire face aux
répercussions économiques de la pandémie
est les deux dirigeants ont appelé les
pays membres à faire preuve de ce
dernier l'europe il faut bien le dire et
avoir cette lucidité a été sans doute
mise en défaut au début de cette crise
d'abord parce que la compétence
sanitaire n'est pas une compétence
communautaire et donc nous ne devons pas
demander à l'union européenne ce qui
n'est pas de sa compétence
aussi parce qu'il ya eu des réflexes
nationalistes en particulier sur la
gestion des frontières y compris à
l'intérieur de l'espace schengen et nous
devons à cet égard tirer toutes les
leçons de cette pandémie
nous devons aussi dire que des actions
remarquables au niveau européen ont été
conduites
l'europe doit être solidaire c'est ce
pour quoi il s'agit d'avoir une reprise
économique rapide et c'est pourquoi nous
voulons mettre en place un fonds
temporaire de 500 milliards d'euros
des lieux devrait fournir des dépenses
budgétaires c'est à dire non pas des
prêts mais des dépenses budgétaires ou
les secteurs et les régions les plus
écoutées l'analyse de françois poulet
mathis journalistes spécialisés
institutions européennes insi n'est pas
question que ce fonds servent à combler
des trous
sinon ça n'a pas de sens donc la
vocation de ce fonds de 500 milliards
c'est de l'investissement c'est de
relancer la machine
si par la fin ça se traduit par de la
dette
il s'agit de bonnes dettes vous savez
très bien qu'il ya la bonne dette et il
ya la mauvaise d'être la mauvaise dette
c'est celle qui est la dette du puits
sans fonds c'est les dépenses publiques
qui n'ont pas d'effet que sur l'économie
la bonne dette c'est celle qui se
traduit par des investissements en
matière de transformation économique en
matière de modernisation économique de
rendre l'économie plus verte ça c'est de
la bonne dette
il s'agit donc de dette qui pourrait se
contracter sur cette base
or une dette qui est une bonne qui est
saine
c'est pas une mauvaise dette et donc
c'est ça que finalement allemagne comme
france reconnaisse des deux côtés donc
c'est bien de ça dont il s'agit faire
que l'europe retrouve à la fois une
autonomie une souveraineté et peut-être
j'ajouterai comme pierre angulaire une
certaine forme d'énergie qui lui a
sacrément manqué très bonnes nouvelles
en italie le bilan quotidien passe sous
la barre des 100 décès tout juste un peu
plus de 99 morts lors des dernières 24
heures les italiens qui avancent petit à
petit vers un retour à la normale la
phase 2 du plan d confinement est entré
en vigueur aujourd'hui commerces
restaurants et cafés ont rouvert tout
comme les lieux de culte
quentin mauclair des clients assis en
terrasse
une image que l'on n'avait plus
l'habitude de voir ces derniers mois
premier pays européen touché par le
coronavirus l'italie se relève peu à peu
ce lundi le plan de déconfinement est
entré dans sa deuxième phase
les restaurants bars et commerces
peuvent de nouveau accueillir du public
la confédération patronale comptes
commerciaux estiment que près de 800000
commerce sont en principe concernées par
la reprise d'activité comme ici à rome
les serveurs masqué attentes des clients
mais ils sont peu nombreux à s'asseoir
pour profiter d'un café ou d'un plat
nous nous sentons presque ému car cela
fait deux mois que nous ne sommes pas
allés manger au restaurant et je vous
dirai ce que nous en pensons dès que
nous aurons fini de manger mais ce n'est
pas pareil nous sommes assis loin l'un
de l'autre
nous devons parler plus fort donc on va
faire plus de bruit autre symbole du
retour progressif à la normale les lieux
de culte ont eux aussi rouvert leurs
portes au public le duomo de milan a
accueilli ses fidèles tout en appliquant
les mesures strictes en vigueur
désinfection des mains port du masque
nombre de personnes limitées à
l'intérieur et distanciation physique
au vatican le pape françois a célébré
une messe à la basilique saint pierre
il en va de même à rome
prêtre était satisfait de pouvoir tenir
un office après deux mois de confinement
je pense qu'il était très sage de
reprendre les metz lundi afin que nous
puissions aussi voir un peu comment les
fidèles se comportent les petites choses
à mettre en place
c'est une sorte de répétition générale
avant le grand jour que sera dimanche de
son côté le gouvernement veut éviter une
deuxième vague
la prudence est de mise malgré le besoin
urgent de relancer l'activité économique
walt date entre brienz be less nos
principes restent les mêmes ce sont nos
valeurs
il s'agit en premier lieu de protéger la
vie la santé des citoyens
ces principes ces valeurs sont non
négociables mais nous devons les
appliquer de façon spécifique durant
cette deuxième phase nous ne pouvons pas
nous permettre d'attendre la découverte
et la distribution d'un vaccin
nous nous retrouverions alors avec un
outil productif et un contexte social
fortement dégradé
la vie reprend progressivement son cours
en italie
la prochaine étape du déconfinement
amènera la réouverture des gymnases
piscines et centres sportifs
cette nouvelle étape est annoncée pour
le 25 mai prochain la belgique passe au
stade 2 de sons déconfinement ce lundi
également les écoles reprennent
progressivement sauf pour les classes
maternelles elles les commerçants comme
les coiffeurs ou esthéticiennes peuvent
désormais accueillir des clients
idem pour les musées les parcs
animaliers certains bâtiments
historiques ou encore les marchés
limités à 50 commerçants enfin les
entraînements sportifs en extérieur sont
autorisés avec 20 personnes maximum
la communauté éducative se félicite de
cette réouverture des classes pour les
6e primaire tout a été organisé de sorte
qu'ils aient des entrées des points
d'entrée différents dans l'école et
qu'ils aient leur propre itinéraire de
passage pour arriver dans leurs locaux
les locaux ont été organisées de sorte
qu'il y ait bien quatre mètres carrés
par enfant et oui m² pour l'enseignant
je suis convaincu qu'au niveau social et
au niveau psychologique c'était
important que les enfants aient un
contact entre eux et avec
l'institution avec leur institutrice
leur instituteur reprendre contact c'est
absolument indispensable
le déconfinement commence hongrie les
habitants de budapest ont pu sortir de
chez eux aujourd'hui après deux mois et
demi de restriction la hongrie compte
officiellement 3535 4019 fait 462 morts
les habitants de la capitale hongroise
ont exprimé leur joie de pouvoir se
déplacer librement
je suis vraiment heureuse que les
restrictions et était arrivé je vais
pouvoir acheter tout ce dont j'ai besoin
de bons et de mauvais aspects
connaissons les gens ici je pense que ça
ira avec un sentiment de grande
libération et de rassemblements de masse
il y aura peut-être aussi une sorte
d'irresponsabilité qui sait trouver une
réponse commune face aux coronavirus
c'était l'objectif cet après midi à
l'assemblée annuelle de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé la visioconférence
a réuni les représentants des 194 pays
membres de cette agence onusienne sur
fond de tensions persistantes
washington rejette sur la chine et l'
oms la responsabilité de la crise qui
frappe les états unis et le monde
alors que faut-il retenir de cette
journée les détails avec le cas tu as
une conférence sous tension dès les
premières minutes le secrétaire général
de l'onu donne le ton nous avons entendu
beaucoup de messages de solidarité mais
nous n'avons pas vu beaucoup d'unités
dans notre réponse au qu'ovide 19
certains pays ont adopté des stratégies
différentes parfois contradictoires et
aujourd'hui le monde entier en paye le
prix fort
une introduction salé à destination des
pays qui n'ont pas respecté les
recommandations de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé dans le viseur
d'antonio goûter res notamment les états
unis
si washington s'en prend régulièrement à
l'onu depuis des années c'est maintenant
son institution en charge de la santé
qui cristallise sa colère donald trump
accuse le ms de n'être que le
porte-parole de pékin dans cette crise
sanitaire
résultat le mois dernier en pleine
pandémie
le président américain a suspendu la
contribution financière américaine à
l'om est ce la privant ainsi de 15% de
son budget total la chine déclenche
aussi les foudres de la maison blanche
elle est accusée de très mauvaise
gestion et de dissimulation de la
propagation du virus
une allégation démentie une nouvelle
fois cet après midi par le président
chinois aux hommes we have a great
reprenait tout au long des événements
nous avons agi dans un esprit
d'ouverture de façon transparente et
responsable
nous avons fourni des informations à
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
aux pays concernés en temps et en heure
nous avons communiqué la séquence du
génome du virus le plus rapidement
possible nous avons partagé sans réserve
de notre expérience et notre savoir
médical avec le monde entier
nous avons fait tout ce qui était en
notre pouvoir pour aider les pays en
difficulté la chine va donner 2
milliards de dollars américains sur une
période de deux ans pour lutter contre
le coronavirus si un vaccin chinois
contre le coc vie 19 est découvert il
sera considéré comme un bien public
mondial
un bien public mondial c'est aussi
l'idée défendue par la france
au milieu de cette crise sanitaire paris
tente de jouer les médiateurs et appelle
en finir avec les tensions diplomatiques
mais au moment où les soignants du monde
entier se bat avec bravoure contre le
coronavirus ne pourrons pas nous
permettre d'être divisés nous n'avons
pas le droit de fuir nos responsabilités
nous devons au contraire d assumer
collectivement pour être efficace nous
avons ici l'opportunité de lutter d'une
seule voix contre l'épidémie
sans complaisance mais aussi sans
accusation a fondé nous devons être unis
exigent est clair c'est notre devoir
le texte présenté aujourd'hui aux 194
pays membres demandent la mise en place
d'un processus d'évaluation pour
examiner la pertinence des mesures
sanitaires recommandé par l'om est ce au
cours des derniers mois sera-t-il
adopter ou non
réponse attendue à genève ce mardi est
les états ne peuvent plus faire cavalier
seul la réponse doit obligatoirement
être internationale face à deux
telle épidémie c'est l'avis de baratte
pangkhan ya expert en maladies
infectieuses
le problème est que msc que les états
membres protègent leurs positions
respectives
nous perdons donc au niveau de la
science il ya un peu plus de politique
dans les roues à celle oms des états
membres défendent leurs intérêts leur
posture il serait mieux que des experts
des états membres qui ne seraient pas
impartiaux envers ses états membres
nous avons des différences d'opinion au
niveau de la gestion de l'épidémie
les coréens du sud ont fait du très bon
travail ils sont restés les contacte
alors que les etats-unis ont fait tout à
fait le contraire on dit ce n'est pas un
problème pour les états unis et n'ont
pas accompli ce qu'il aurait dû faire à
temps alors même qu'il bénéficiait d'
avertissement très clair donc appelé les
pays asiatiques les chinois les coréens
les taiwan et les habitants de singapour
ont fait du très bon travail très
rapidement et européens l'italie en tout
cas a été prise de court et les
américains ont tout simplement décidé
qu'il ne fallait pas s'en soucier
effectivement nous avons besoin d'une
santé publique internationale qui
travaille dans l'unité qui décide d'un
plan sinon effectivement ce genre de
catastrophe se reproduira et c'est la
fin de ce journal prochain point complet
sur l'actualité demain 7h du matin heure
française excellente fin de soirée tous
faire des france
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la veille d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient des guignols
aujourd'hui on est une gauche
extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
ma vie est dit